otherwise everything was so delayed
really boom hello everybody and welcome
to the masters companion here on all
things comedy on court McGowan we got
Steve Rannazzisi hello everybody
we got sticks it in you from Steel
Panther it's really nice to be here yeah
I'm so happy and we got Jason gore hello
everybody good to see you man to be
gonna be here we got master Sunday guys
yes we're back again this is sizzle
we're not starting this off with two
[ __ ] idiots in Butler cabin don't
know where to put their hands it's
uncomfortable and by the way how many
[ __ ] do you think these old men have
banged in Butler cabin back in the day
all of them don't you think I think the
number is so high that you can't count I
can't count that number no no humans can
yeah yeah but Butler cabin C I don't
know I just if those walls could talk I
feel like they would they would want to
they would need a lawyer they'd be
dripping we were talking before we got
on the air about because this is like
Super Bowl Sunday for corporate America
yeah other than the real actual Super
Bowl Sunday what do you think the
prostitute population down to Augusta
this week is is you think it's gets high
it's interesting you bring that up where
do they I don't see a I don't think it
gets higher higher than normal because I
think that the normal Augusta hookers
are like I'm out cuz they're probably
like a B squad so they're like I'm going
to Atlanta I'm gonna go to Tallahassee
it's December I'm in Augusta I go to
back page I gotta find a hooker those
girls that I'm looking at they're not
there this we're out there around the
road this is Super Bowl weekend for
they're going in there they're bringing
in the big guns and all the fine [ __ ]
yep from around the country and world
maybe they're in Augusta now and they
all stay in Butler cabin yes they do
welcome well at some point yeah well not
to get away from the [ __ ] but we do
have a golf tournament going on and
let's just take a look at what's going
on the same thing we said last year
applies this year Rickie Fowler's in and
again yeah Paul Casey's
making a run but this year you got
Patrick Stewart at the top that's agree
attrex - it happens
tubing ya know that Patrick Stewart
Patrick Stewart was the starter starter
Patrick Reed [ __ ] nerd
alright and then and then we have Rory
McIlroy McIlroy and who's making a run
right now is this little kid by the name
of jordan Spieth yeah he's making a
[ __ ] runny what do you say little kid
I pictured like an eight-year-old out
there
he doesn't think an eight-year-old I
know you I know you picture an
eight-year-old but kid meaning over the
age of 18 okay there you go little kid
but yeah Spieth's actually 5-under today
he's got one of the best rounds on the
golf he's only just finished nine right
he's going to town he's going to 10th
Paul Casey out there by the way 9-under
today he's going for a course record Oh
another guy last year we talked about
him coming down the stretch he just
plays well there wait Casey is 9-under
right now 499 under 7-under for the day
right no no Casey now is 8-under he just
bogeyed 17 so he is no yeah he's 6-under
total today he's 8-under all right so
let's just say right now we were on life
if you had to pick a winner right now go
around the table right now I'd say all
things stand right now
Rory Wow look at that wait guys are
flipping and flopping I'm coming in with
aapanaadu definitive call right that
just sounded like someone just like Rory
I love Rolex
if you want to but I yeah go ahead go
ahead I'm jordan Spieth you're going
jordan Spieth yep I'm going John Rama
you're going John wrong if we're not if
we're not picking Reed yeah if you can't
pick whoever you want
Reed if you want to I like ROM I think I
think there's a lot of Spanish like
ghosts oh really Wow would you see
Sergio putting on a jacket on John ROM
would be a nice Barcelona be going crazy
what about you
I listen I unfortunately I mean not
unfortunately but I I'm still gonna go
with Fowler making a huge charge on the
back nine yeah I've I mean I know he I
mean he right now he is one through he's
five out of it right now so that's a
that's a bold call but I know my heart
my heart my heart goes
I want to see fair that's a sound sounds
like a sentimental call yeah it is
sounds like a like an unwise yeah I was
gonna ask before assuming that you guys
your picks don't win let's just say
Fowler and John ROM don't win either one
of them went today who do you think wins
therefore a foot major first John ROM or
Rickie Fowler going forward from today
because I think both those guys I mean
well that's a good question till after I
would like to say Fowler but he's been
doing it longer than ROM
so I'm gonna say it on the trajectory
roms on it's gonna be wrong what do you
what John Rob's what 22 years yeah he
was a rookie last year I know it he's 22
I mean I think with John ROM is he's so
he hits the ball so far I mean you're a
tour player you've you know how many
years were you on PGA Tour well this is
my 21st year yeah so 21 so 21 years out
there do you feel like when you're like
because Fowler's now he's one players
which was a huge deal that was like the
fifth major he's one that you know two
years ago he finished top five in all
four majors which is very difficult to
do yeah but to get over that hump it's
like you know it's that final round
Sunday that he's not really coming
through with nor is ROM at this point so
I I I don't think you I mean I I still
say I think Fowler where I think Fowler
pull it off I see I think there's gets
to a point where some guys play well
trying really hard you know acting like
basketball players you know like they
like give the effort some guys don't
play well but some guys just go out and
have a good time playing you know I'm
just and let things come to them like
roms the kind of guy that I think plays
really really well the harder he tries
yeah okay yeah and Ricky kind of really
wants it so bad and I mean there was a
time when Sergio didn't think he was
gonna win yeah you mentioned that yeah I
think both of them will eventually end
up winning majors both of them I mean I
think ROM will end up winning more just
because he's younger but I I just AM
interest to see who well I think Ray
also first I think ROM does it first did
pressure on him doing it yeah I think
you also find it but I disagree I think
there's more pressure on wrong because
Fowler doesn't I mean he's set he's got
the sponsorships he's got so
robbed us - yeah yeah those guys I feel
like they want wins by the way actual
wins by the way he doesn't have a lot of
either by the way we are in the all
things comedy studio here in beautiful
downtown Burbank California
but Jason Gore brought pimento cheese
sandwiches this is gore made those mrs.
Gore made these this is what they serve
mom made them yeah that's awesome
no you see Bubba put it into the bunker
before D really cheesy he had to go up
into the rough it's cheese Wow calm down
and he caught up in it it caught up
something a rock or something and it
started going this way and you could
just see him it just that's not the
right holder so if you're following
along that wants to drive big I'll get
to that in a minute
I mean I don't want to so much filth but
did you there's a we'll get to the
article in the Sun about this guy in
England who had sex with a golf ball
okay saw that doesn't really get to it
talk about it we don't have to talk of
filthily about it I showed it to court
hopefully nothing worth these no more
tape this guy did you see that
no he's an English guy next commercial
maybe I'll throw it up I don't know
please don't throw it up I'll tweet it
out but yeah no reenactments please know
they have a video of it they somewhat
videotaped in Omaha videotape the guy
does this and then he walks off like big
yeah almost like he's you know he's
embarrassed he just [ __ ] a golf hall
and he used the to stick to [ __ ] his ass
while he was doing it oh wait double bro
hold on double down on it for real he
was the human hole like he made himself
like the hole was the middle centipede
yes amazing it was yes I wish I see this
and I'll get you the video right now oh
my god took read on six but with a
flagstick yeah this is really master
sunday ladies read on the seventh hole
here good approach here right back down
oh here comes got a chance to go in
folks
oh oh boy he is just you know animal or
way out eyes it's supposed to break love
plays Chris down that's the par-5 right
that's seven that's no par four okay
that's incredible shot out of the rough
there I mean that's the thing with Regis
he is so powerful second coming yeah can
we yeah there's no real real look I
don't know Patrick Reed you know Patrick
green a little bit yeah what's your
experience with him been he's always
been fine to me I mean you know it's not
like I have his phone number anything
but I don't even know if he knows my
name but yeah so he's a dick well yeah I
mean I've never really I mean I like
he's been cool to you you need to say
anything yeah he's been saying I don't
know you you know you don't like him you
just don't I don't dislike him I just
don't have a fondness for him there's
other people I pull for there's these
are not one of them that come off a
little more friendly you know you know
on TV that look we can say that right
yeah I mean I've seen like interviews
and stuff he seems fine and like nice
and stuff but on the course he's
competitive and I think he probably rubs
people the wrong way
I bet you he likes to party though well
yes even it is this you gotta be there's
a hell of a shy Rory McIlroy punching
from underneath the tree going back to
what I said throw the green sorry about
that
going back to what you said before about
how certain people play John Rowe I
think Patrick Reed plays best when he is
and like it was so whatever it takes to
get to that point whether it's like I
hate the guy in front of me or that guy
I don't know whatever it is he's got to
get there so you know
chip-on-the-shoulder
yeah they can the motivation someone he
can rub people I guess the wrong way
that's why don't you don't maybe not
necessarily rooting for he would be like
coyote yeah Karl Malone you want him on
your team yeah and you don't want to
play it yeah you want him on a rider cut
team yeah sure he's an asset for sure
yeah you want him as a team but I think
that was like great a great example of
his attitude or his personality was when
him and Rory were back going back and
forth and he does the shushing the crowd
thing and it's like alright we get you
know but the shishi
Kevin my young dude you gotta say like
that did do is a 27-20
that generation grew up on YouTube
whereas like you know dunk videos and
like people getting embarrassed and like
just showmanship gamesmanship where it's
like they're turning golf into like
words like I would have had more respect
if he to grab his nuts and like what
didn't find them
he's shushing the American crowd yeah
that's what I mean you're at Hazeltine
right now is that where they were
Hazeltine er yeah I think searching the
American crowd but like the one button
okay now let me ask you a question what
you think about Rory waiting to give
them a knuckles at the end of the after
he did well that's almost respect Yeah
right but not a respect that's why it's
like you really watch an MMA fight
two guys have just a killer round with
trying to kill each other and then they
you know at the end they just DAP you
know yeah it's like oh this is a great
butts right during Spieth on ten for
birdie and this guy's made it to
10-under
Spieth is on fire he's 5-under for the
day and I mean this is where you go 10th
you birdie 10 your birdie you need a
birdie 10 this is a lot like the putt
maybe just put the ball on the green on
12 not in the water yeah this is the
putt like Nicholas had an 86 and that he
made oh boy
putt the Crenshaw made in 84 turn come
on come on
I think he's I think we're gonna see
something out of speed today something
yeah I mean I mean looks playing with
Justin Thomas who's gonna pushing their
friends you know yeah I mean you also
have I mean the big keys are 13 and 15
you know for him that's 12 who would you
rather be in a fistfight with Justin
Thomas or jordan Spieth I think winning
this fight yeah well yeah I think jordan
Spieth would rather fight Jordan yeah I
think Justin would be more formidable
upon you go take off that hat Baldy and
then he starts to pile it would be more
calculated but Justin Thomas is a watt
he hits the ball far from arm yeah
you're gonna probably get a sucker punch
EDMC cop that's what I'm saying I'd
rather fight Spieth because he's long
calculated a little bit yeah they both
seem like they'd kick below the belt oh
yeah they both seem like they would kick
you in the do both who's want to win so
bad they're gonna even if he got him
they're gonna it's just impossible Shox
if he throws that up any higher it goes
way past the hole
so he's did what he could do by the way
we want to thank Aaron for being there
Aaron what do you got I'll be my
grandfather again yeah we'll talk last
day around our second shot on the eighth
hole high that's on the right side all
right we got a caller who's calling in
hello hey who is this
JP Tracy where are you calling from
Tracy yeah Germany Germany how are you
are you crazy yeah I think she wants to
talk to sticks talk to me talk to me
Tracy what I love you all right well
Tracy this is sticks hey thank you so
much I appreciate that Jeremy are you
what are you wearing Tracy I'm just
wearing my bra and my panties all right
oh you're touching yourself what time is
it in Germany right now it's it's it's
10:00 that's awesome Tracy well we're
glad you called are you enjoying the
golf oh yeah everybody's watching you
right we're all here I think she's
talking about the other guys in my band
oh they took an uber and they're still
they're still on their way if they're
circling yeah where it is thank you
very see you know what this is why I'm
line this week
I can get you know Tracy this is why
they had me on this show and I
appreciate you for you Thank You Tracy
are you you're a big henrik stenson fan
than i assume right is that or bernhard
langer she loves your the best you
really are
what a great hey no one could say we
aren't worldly we just went
international deaf that's right last
year we had my grandfather call from
Florida and this year Tracy's flicking
her bean in Frankfurt I'm gonna go take
a shower
no not yet did let it dry let it dry
well Tracy
we appreciate it I hope you're enjoying
the golf and the fantasy is sucking my
dick Oh perfect sounds an appointment
astok all right upon the book I'll have
his dick people call your mouth people I
love you Tracy take care all right guys
Wow I hope that wasn't your heart
language wife I'll tell you that right
now
porn stuff out we got the I didn't send
you the video yet trace and then Tracy's
gonna blow you in Germany is gonna blow
sticks that was Fenton by the way just
huge announcement I'm opening for a
Steel Panther in Germany for their whole
German tour Tracy ba ba ba do oh my god
you guys do a meet-and-greet yeah well
I'll tell you what man this is taking
off so Fowler's got a shot here on on
number eight this is not easy
because he's short-sighted yeah oh great
oh my here we go way to go kid wait
helps what it's on the upslope there put
a little spin on it yeah I mean this is
where to get back to golf after that not
for me at all I do it all the time on
the golf course I don't have no problem
no it's usually about quick change
usually yells something that makes
everyone comfortable and he lines a putt
up in it yeah and then I make it yeah no
I think I think this is where you're
gonna see eight nine ten eight nine ten
is where you're gonna see somebody
that's gonna break out if they get
because I mean that's what I was Rory
yesterday chipped in on 8th for Eagle
that turned everything around there's a
huge shot here yeah Rob you need to go
to something down the save par let it
adjust over that little Ridge there I
think you can throw it up in the air and
try to spend oh he did too Wow amazing
and what do you think what do you think
the greens are rolling out there do you
think they're rolling 13 today um yeah
probably at least probably 13 14 I'm
guessing I mean they never tell you
that's their thing they don't tell you
I'll tell you what do you mean they
don't tell you they just won't tell you
that's part of their Gustav mystique
just like they won't tell you what the
prize money is we don't know what the
purses of this really that was 11 they
don't they don't post the purse the next
day like in the newspaper in the next
yeah but but players don't know going
into is it vary from year to year I mean
yeah yeah there's it based on
sponsorships and stuff like that they
wait to see who wins I mean they have
what to sponsors or say yes or 18 tees
one or whoever yeah they always have
like two commercials that's it yeah one
one commercial minute an hour and then
the rest of time you've got all these
guys walking around their tippy toes so
they don't piss off the you know though
elite white dudes it kind of like us
yeah he's nice in there I know yeah I
have a buddy who's whose friend got into
a Gus and I was like how did he and he's
like a member of peach tree in Atlanta
which is is a very exclusive club too
even more exclusive than I think then
Augusta in a sense it's very difficult
but he said he asked his friend how he
got in and his friend like made them a
bunch of money and that's like cuz I
don't think it costs much to join
Augusta National no I the old saying is
if you want to be a member in Augusta
you won't be yeah exactly you have to be
invited you can't just say hey I really
really there we go Rickie Fowler for
birdie on eight gets it back to 9-under
okay here we go
huge you don't ask to be a member to
guys but they ask you that's right yeah
Wow that should be their slogan you
don't ask we ask you
how many times you played Augusta zero
zero times your I won on tour they tied
like a two or three year rule where they
took the win it in out the win out
the winning in yeah oh my god that was
me are you kidding me year I've never
been that I won't step foot like I had a
good buddy of mine play there on Sunday
before them before this tournament like
a week ago to get and he invited me to
go play and I'm like no yeah cuz I kind
of like I mean that that purgatory where
if I go play well I've given up on the
yeah that's really actually going to by
being in yeah ornament yeah but if I go
play then it might be like well that was
next time would you say yes you will
play I'll sure do it's the beard its yep
yeah it's gotta be the beard
it's then the hairline and McIlroy here
on the 8th hole second shot out of the
trees now this is this is where I mean
this pine straw place draws a [ __ ] to
play out of although you do get solid
you know there's no you can get a good
look at the ball I think but it's hard
you're gonna move yes it's harder to
keep your footing yeah
now this is ROM is this for par for par
big pie okay this is a good putter he is
he is he from Barcelona to yeah I think
so but he went to ASU for he doesn't
look 22
he looks like he's like 38 yeah he's
from Spain he looks like a Lego
character jarhead yeah all right beats
on 11 second shot on 11 now this is the
this is still the toughest hole in the
course 11 yeah I think it was crossing
between 11 and 7 yeah this is the
longest part for yeah and this a crazy
shot and I think they have the pin back
left which makes it insane oh boy yeah
there you go
that looks like an uphill putt right it
is uphill putt and I mean that's the
thing those are those like 20 footers
that Spieth is just insane he just D
dunks him you know it's it's different
than anybody I think he trusts his line
they just catch the ball aids
yeah Nick Faldo in 89 but that was
against wasn't that against Greg Norman
when he another one collapsing buildings
yeah don't forget he shot 67 that round
who did fouled it no I know but I think
but I think what's his uh Norman had a
ridiculously yeah he was up by like
eight strokes going in right that guy's
good Tommy Fleetwood it's really rock
star yeah I don't know why I like that
guy I just hope he looks like he's got a
swing that her no he hope he stays
healthy yeah he's always like turning
and you know it turns well but it's
always just gotta let you just love I
like the name Fleetwood it's just so
it's it's tight mail like his hair yeah
yeah and he looks like from back in the
day when they didn't have Dennis you
know he's got that English didn't really
mouth yeah yeah did you have a high
pitched voice I picture him ever high no
he sounds like this oh speaking of
English I'm happy that Ian Poulter won
last week oh I like him know that the
tour [ __ ] up and told him yes I did a
match play that he was in or that he had
earned enough to be top fifty which
would have got him in and then so when
he lost when he won his quarterfinal
match right
they told him hey your don't worry like
you don't have to win anymore you're
good then right before he tees off he
[ __ ] up you've got to win this match
that's when he goes down like eight
stroke he was sound like eight in like
geez like the first you guys see that
Ian Poulter Cole weeks ago I'm happy
that he won in Houston because he wasn't
they [ __ ] with him bad at that
Accenture Match Play they told him that
he was in he had earned enough after he
won his quarterfinal ranch and then
they've realized were they did he didn't
so right before he tees off for a semi
final man I got a witness that we [ __ ]
up and that's when he was down like
seven like seven and eight right away
didn't he think he was out he thought he
was out well yeah it was a different
time yeah he was out like one of your
last masters yeah last year he was on a
major medical
right and he almost lost his car yeah
well no what they told him is they told
him if he didn't finish a certain number
he was gonna lose his car yeah he missed
by one stroke and then Brian gays wife
actually because Brian paperwork no
Brian gays why figured it out and goes
hey you guys [ __ ] up he was on medical
yeah and he's he's not off to her he's
on tour and so as my husband yeah it's
like so that but then this year they
[ __ ] up again right before that
semi-finals no I know but then he goes
out and wins Houston the next week it's
crazy that was a big win in Houston to
know is a huge one yeah it's hard to
believe I was his first stroke play win
it wasn't in America yeah yeah I mean
he's one Matt or did he went mad or
whatever it's called del now wow you
know I'm surprised like you know you see
some of these guys and it's like you
keep going that guy's never won and
you're like you gotta work in with Paul
Casey slice yeah Fowler's only won four
times I'm a commercial yeah yeah I want
a commercial now that's what I'm saying
it's like that's perfect time you expect
a guy like that to have more wins than
for what Sun I expect when you use see
Ricky Fowler and the popularity and you
expect him to have eight wins well I
mean I think John roms probably got
three already um I think he does he's
got one
he won twice last year he won twice last
year so he's got two wins yeah he won
Torrey Pines last year and I think he
won another one he won the farmers last
year and in another one is that the only
one he wait for it wait for it here we
go
sticks over there but I wouldn't think
he's yeah yeah go ahead get some pizza
you big little [ __ ] you wanna you want
to know that should we get some more
calls from Germany by the way I heard up
with a live one yeah real [ __ ] last
year we started up with migrant Tracey's
my wife's grandfather called from
Florida he's like I can't believe you
guys are on this Traci top that this
year big-time
Tracy game it hot yeah she did she had a
purpose she didn't give a [ __ ] that we
try to mold her back into like a golf
fan she was like now I'm just here to
suck dicks
I just want to suck dicks [ __ ] your goal
by the way if you're out there and
you're oh what do we got here that's
yeah if you want to call in you feel
free to call in at three two three two
eight two seven four two four that's
three two three two eight two seven four
two four happy rotational calls any
other people from Germany don't want to
blow sticks come on in break in the hall
no short Jordan firm that has a chance I
think right Lester
Oh Reed I think I talked about this last
year but again terrible choice for chert
if you know you want to win a green
jacket you got to think about what
you're gonna wear white he'd wear white
[ __ ] yeah dude I beam all-white he said
look like the Good Humor man he scripted
then you slip that green jacket on me
bro you look [ __ ] tight [ __ ]
alright bro all right I'm not mad would
you wear a green shirt with a white
white white shirt with a green like
highlight oh I might like be a green
stripe on that way when the jacket goes
on yeah exactly yeah I like Fleetwood
War like these look at this we've
switched gears here Fleetwood War like
this all green outfit on Thursday I
thought it was but it was like it wasn't
masters green it was like an off mint
green that was pretty tight all right
how about orange and green that's
another thing it's like a combo gray
combo he knows I don't know that's like
his thing that kind of these guys are
scripted Nike tells them what to wear do
you notice that all of them all the Nike
guys yesterday were wearing blue shirts
yeah oh yeah they were all scripted oh
really when I was with Nike and played
in the open they they tell you what -
well I know like I follow a lot of these
guys on Instagram like you know Dustin
Johnson's got all his adidas [ __ ] laid
out and like so it's like he's got you
know if it rains on Thursdays got seven
there
Alfred so he's got it planned out but I
assumed that was him planning it out
like I would be like hey dude hey Mikey
guess what I'm wearing all why not
[ __ ] Thursday
I mean I'm Sunday bro I've dreamt about
this my whole life
now just because your checks have
afforded me a lifestyle that I kind of
yeah if you can't keep your quarter
billion dollars Nike the word roll why
why I'm wearing [ __ ] white on master
Sunday what color is he wearing he's
wearing pink - pink - see he's the only
Tigers allowed to pick out what he wants
to wear out Oh got mad at Reid for
wearing red on Sunday he did but he's
not doing it today I think it's
unwritten now just you don't don't do it
Tiger did it would you ever wear red on
Sunday yeah why not
I have [ __ ] like would you though I
mean I go black shirt red pants though
yeah but you wouldn't go red shirt and
and I'm not saying because it's respect
you just I don't know if it's even
respect it's just that's just what he
does and it would just come off as like
either you weren't button black and red
you got a red bandana on you
I would do it but I'm not a pro golfer
oh here we go give your bro you'd be
like oh that was horrible I know what a
feeling but that wasn't this year so we
haven't talked about this yet Sergio's
13 115th old on day one my god I'll tell
you what it was like 10 car I've seen
you play like that
jaren I've seen you do that like yeah I
mean can you swallow first great right
could we get Tracy back on the line I
got around myself yeah I saw that movie
can you swallow first no the way I see
it is like that was one of those things
where he just kept going and kept going
I'm not mad at that
no I mean look it wasn't ten Capisce he
was he was actually trying to you know
what how many yards did he have in on
this he trained I don't know why he kept
trying to hit to the right of the pin it
was like all right I'm taking yours
Spieth on the 12th hole this is huge
this is like deja vu right over again
that bunker Jordan that's what was it
Jack Nicholas set up for the bunker and
I look hit in the middle of the green
alright that looks good in between
beautiful yeah perfect two putts on
there make it me yeah that's so good
dude yeah that's like that's like that's
somebody who's having a good time yeah
yeah that's somebody free I'm up for the
ban I know exactly he's got a par 5
coming up and that's the great thing I
mean would you rather play for you know
it you know it you've been on tour a
long time would you rather play from a
group back or two groups back and come
chase somebody down then be have all the
pressure on you going into this thing no
give me the lead give me the lead all
right yeah okay believe okay all right I
like it I hear that a cabin just because
that way now you're controlling right
but but in this thing I mean I think
Paul Casey just showed earlier when he
this is what six hundred a five hole
stretch it's out there you got the wind
it's just it's a little cooler I think
it's out there so these guys have got a
link look up on the leaderboard and see
that in case you by the way case you
gave away to gave two strokes back to
last year so it makes prioritizing all
over those trees just cut the corner all
the roll what's the farthest recorded
drive you've ever hit on tour 427 hello
or 2017 competition in competition where
was this Kapalua
oh yeah on number mm-hmm ten eleven
twelve okay
it was blowing 70 that year yeah you not
that much maybe fifty two oh I had it
down the left side and it blew it over
the green on a 425 you're at all in the
back bunker may the best party ever seen
Matt I place I played Kapalua in 2001 in
the pro-am when it was still the
mercedes-benz pro-am and 18th hole that
we had the wind going going down you
know we're downwind right hit it I hit
driver 6-iron on the green nice but I
was also playing 30 yards yeah you don't
you don't tell that yeah just let it go
yeah
go yeah you should that's to learn to
embellish your stories and make them
like that's information top sounding
okay and I healed it just a little
groove oh they tell when it's a groove
low I mean yeah of course we can really
yeah a groove well I mean it's a saying
okay it's a say it's not like I really
hit it so four strokes back Fowler
maybe Smith ROM McIlroy all tied at
tendon door everybody still four strokes
behind Patrick Reed look at that you
called him you called a measure winner
and he birdies the last two holes yeah
I'm gonna rub up against you Tracy
what's that what happened Dustin I just
think it's one of those things where I
don't think he's been playing enough
I'll be honest I don't think he's really
I mean you know say you're ready I feel
like a lot of these guys like that went
and played last week what a great move
to play you know Houston speeds up the
greens now the Houston open does to get
people a little more ready for Augusta
oh go in the hole Charles yes no Charley
Hoffman I like him how about that green
jacket that's a thing though you for him
glide long hair I you know he doesn't
seem like he's trying to kill the ball
when he swings to get that nice compact
swing
yeah I like Charlie what's his caddies
named Brent Waldman yeah he's probably
saying god what a great club I just
picked right there yeah yeah Brett super
caddie when I was caddy when I was
caddying out I don't don't go running
after him time yeah can we
the ankle yeah do you see ice watch
siren I live last night jost had a great
joke he was like Tony Fein out twisted
his ankle celebrating a hole-in-one on a
par 3 which disproves golfers are not
athletes
shoved it back into place
Oh didn't even show they're like funk to
me yeah yeah it was hard to watch I know
but by the way that's happened in
football like I think one of the
gramática brothers like tours ACL
celebrating like winning a winning cake
or something like that the best
hole-in-one on the hole par 3 was Jack
Nicklaus his grandson was amazing oh
yeah that's up and hits a hole-in-one
never had not swung the club all day
steps up high school kid 15 years I now
eighteenth our ninth hole on the par 3
hits it perfect spot spins it back you
got a special trip to Butler's cabin
Phil look out John 15 did he hit it
[Applause]
oh this is trouble now uh-uh
dude he's actually I got it oh boy here
we go that you know Patrick reads and
listening that reverberating through the
pines I hope so
I hope he just five shot improvement
from yeah links under now right for this
round nobody makes well that was two
years ago is close it two years and
years yes claps good for you Jordan yeah
but I still love that he you know that
people have that hanging over him so
when he puts it on the green he's like
oh yeah oh yeah I promise
relief from that at Club link form I
think you just took a drop yeah oh he
did take a drop I promise me Jordan hit
ten extra nine irons today on the range
oh yeah guaranteed he's been thinking
about that for have you played yes super
good guy one of the nicest guys and I
and I love and I love Grell ER I thought
Grell er was a really nice guy and I met
him when he was still he still was
teaching so he was just yet part-time
like that he became like yeah a good
caddie like just through hard work like
you could tell this is him like his
god-given thing he caddied for Justin
Thomas and the amateur have us the us
amateurs at chambers Bay in Seattle and
that's how he met Jordan and then so he
started catting for Jordan on his you
know PGA Tour sponsors exemptions and
then they you know ended up winning and
they'd have friends ever since
can we just I don't think we just
addressed the [ __ ] up that Patrick we
just made know what happened you just
hit it short it short rolled back into
the background yeah you couple that with
you setting it up and down now I think
if we just leave Patrick Reed alone for
a little bit maybe he'll just completely
[ __ ] up and we never have to talk I'm
about to do it don't talk to Patrick
come on
see that's that's a perfect spot to go
to exactly that's the guy that's gonna
win I call him calling it this could be
a pivotal already you who already I'm
recalling it give a recall stuff 3-wood
I don't see Tracy's number coming back
up she's hitting me on right over the
side and Bumble another three would
probably wat 320 we got a call coming in
go ahead pick it up here a lot of guys
hit three one cuz it's easier to turn it
over yeah you're on the air who's
calling hello mom
Tracy Tracy hopefully it's not my call
drop oh well no more call oh that was
amazing it was such a great call that it
was so clean that great interception is
insane
I like our second caller better than the
first I like the first Oh Jordans
alright not good so we've seen Phil do
it from there yeah yeah one more five
right yeah 13 he can drop a birdie on it
no no I know but yeah he's not gonna go
for it now though he won't go for it if
he's smart he doesn't go for it I think
Fowler made a huge mistake going for it
yesterday yeah this is a big gonna catch
the speed slot down there on the left
no yeah you got it here he goes maybe
that's such a huge difference I mean
what are you talking about 75 80 yards
you
rolls down I mean that's amazing you
know it's two clubs that's the longest
par four right it's at 489 490 but no
that's 11 longer 11s longer Elevens 517
I think it's crazy we got it's got to
get up and down from par here right go
ahead and hit it up Aaron who's calling
hey what's going on right now are you
mid about you we're doing good man you
watching the golf today absolutely gonna
take thing do you think so oh yeah so we
don't think birding 12:00 was that was
it gonna be the catalyst for him to take
off now in the back nine look at this oh
yeah Patrick Reed look at this look at
this recovery for Patrick Reed that's
yeah that's the thing his short game is
ridiculous oh you're gonna you're gonna
take you're gonna take Spieth for this
for the big win for the big win I want
to see him come back and take it right
on bro who's gonna finish second you
think Reed folds or do you think the
matter okay probably put a lot of
thought in the winner but no thought
into second place way to go Steve great
question there all right we're ready
all right well give him a call and let
him know text them know what I think
what we'll definitely a call for sure
from one of them
all right buddy man have a good day
enjoy the rest of the round any other
suggestions war [ __ ] I got that all
right thank you then later dude
enjoy all right so listen man this is
getting a little tighter now but I mean
I was kind of hoping that Reed would hit
a shitty second or third shot up there
and we would see a bogey come out of it
looks like he might know he's sore game
still a nasty putt though I know but I
say I think he saves par here all right
come on Fowler stick this tight Ricky
Fowler second shot here on the 10th hole
after this shot we should talk about
hookers again yeah we can do it while
the ball is in the air I mean I don't I
guess it's gonna be in there for a while
so yeah you'd see how much the rain has
made these green softer yeah Thursday
and Friday they were on fire but that
was the one thing they talked about they
talked about this crazy storm that was
gonna come in to Augusta and it never
happened there was a short like 15
minute period where I mean you saw the
balls all of a sudden going twenty yards
shorter the rain came down the winds
came out but the temperatures dropped
and then everything the Sun came back
out it was like okay alright yeah see
makes it he makes it oh yeah that's a
that's a huge parcei there by Patrick
Reed on nine it was a confident stroke
yeah bang that sucker yeah he's I mean
that's the one thing is I chose a lot
right there
I mean he's even par today alright so
he's even par through nine holes so
front nine he's played even he knows as
well as anybody else does he kiss you
yeah the back nine is where the back
nine is where intimate starts yeah and
you're going into the back nine with a
three shot lead
and you're you're you're sitting way in
the driver's seat do you think he at
this point he's he's looking at the
leaderboard going where is everybody
I'd also just like no I don't think even
I don't you think he checks you think he
checks the leaderboard now at the turn
somebody is if he's not Kessler as his
caddie goes heck hey by the way do you
want to know where you are do they ask
him especially with the par fives on the
back I mean if he's got a two or three
shot lead and he's kind of hits one up
in the pine straw yeah absolutely
he's got five iron in maybe maybe you
just backup layup and who had your
clothes up there yeah I mean I think
also like especially i specially 13 13
is is a huge penalty 15 I mean 15
there's some mitt places to miss it 13
you really you've got to miss it on the
green if you miss it off the green
you're screwed I have a question
alright so if he's playing with the
three shot lead and he hits it in the
pine straw the scenario you brought up
and then he lays up are the other
golfers going [ __ ] you [ __ ] or are they
going
what I would do to you that's what they
do to okay so no one's mad at him for no
no no no if they are they're only mad at
him when he well their magazine is
eclipsed agree when they you know and
they got a you know do a forty four
chubby for the you know the jackets we
have a in the back you know I would have
I would I'd have to go
forty-four chubby bro but that's just
cuz my shoulders are super broad and I'm
awesome
fifty-two long yeah but let me ask you
this when they put the jacket on do you
pour your hair up and like hold it up
while they put the judge no you let the
jacket cascade down on the hair and then
you pull the hair out with both hands
back and let it's a flip hair and then
the [ __ ] that's what Tommy FLE what
has to do oh yeah we would put on the
green jacket without no that would be
sick as [ __ ] yeah cuz he's got the
coolest hair on tour how good would I
know yeah yeah how many guys do you
think that happen guys has got pretty
good hair yeah he's got like a mullet
almost chopped is a little bit how many
guys on tour that wear a green jacket do
you think have had a joint inside the
coat pocket there's gotta be some few
guys in seventies said no sure bernhard
langer burns you'll still have a joint
that's how we get yeah bad that's i mean
how many guys loosened up how many guys
the champions dinner pull a bindle out
of the inside go in the bathroom give a
quick little I like it
tee shot from have you ever played golf
on cocaine yes I have to it's a
miserable could imagine how hot your
self down really is into this putt oh
your brain is like
I was I played in a golf tournament I
was a member of this so Palvin a men's
club and they had that we had the finals
we you know I was a good boy all week
and I was in the final group of the
night somebody picked up the trophy too
soon went out yeah when I fell like 6:00
in the morning had a 7:30 teeth oh my
god and I like did it huge you know a
couple little gags right before I left
before I went to the golf course that's
right the night before that's just
straight and and then we get there and
of course they sent like four groups out
in front of us you know so we're waiting
breakfast yeah is that a sweaty is he
warming up why is he yeah no I like I
mean you can't even swing you know down
but I managed to make it through the
first two holes okay and I was in a golf
cart I couldn't walk you know I could I
was weak anyway
couldn't walk anywhere thinking about
how your feet are moving yeah yeah it's
just like you're paranoid and then I
started coming down and at one point we
had to wait for the group in front of us
and I kind of leaned over the golf cart
come on Fowler sink this putt get up
there hill did yeah it was not pretty
it's the worst it's not good it's
probably worse things you can do high on
blow is go oh she's going for it you
think Jim Nancy's going out and we're
talking about this off of there probably
boy probably no got it
2:23 all he's saying
Oh Jordan speith Wow second shot on
13-footer
right there his head was down and in his
mind he was thinking this [ __ ] all you
he was also yelling go at the ball like
and praying they barely got up once it
got things like [ __ ] yeah Wow
so Spieth is sitting three shots back he
makes battle fodder for Eagle which
would get him to 12 get him to 13 13 get
him at 13 he's 11-under right now one
back
Spieth yeah look at him two one one one
back and and Reed is not sitting good
right now in the 10th he's high he
pulled the shirt that is a tight man
green shirt I would and with the white
pant combo Walker came to play he's had
a rough time since winning the PGA had
Lyme disease yeah that's yeah real bad
some guy was sleeping with his wife Lyme
disease [ __ ] your wife I think the tick
yeah the tickle take you the tick will
take your blood and the wife Justin
Thomas it actually means nothing but I
mean the semi Reid right here for Jordan
I know I do
well now Jordan saw that George Sarris
to the leg to the right but it's but
he's a little bit he's got a little bit
straighter puck cuz he's a little bit
further down the slope
I know I know coming from above this
hole doesn't go left so so I think he's
gonna be but there is the you know the
12th green which they say is the pole
yeah that's God so he's got a little
it's gonna be a little bit left to right
I think is just love you know I was down
there rolling balls on the green
I hate it when they say that it's like
you you were not I've seen you
[ __ ] out there and you walk
around in the morning you you have
breakfast inside practice know that
Faldo and Nance New Mexico I'm gonna
roll balls on the green [ __ ] you Faldo
should probably know I mean but I don't
knows how it breaks but no these that's
the amazing these greens have really not
changed no no no yeah I think they just
said they resurface twelve is that right
I mean that's well you know this area
top right yeah I mean I've got to do
something yeah but like but I mean it's
like Torrey Pines north they completely
redid greens totally so you have no idea
what those greens do because nobody's
ever played him before does does he make
this putt he makes this doesn't make
this mess but this putts going left edge
and firm yeah I like this come on Joey's
putt for Eagle on the 13th hole come on
Jordan here we go come on kid knock it
in yeah all right so birdies 12 I'm the
only thing that sucks about this is you
pretty much I mean you know you know
Reed's probably gonna birdie 13 well the
par fives are yeah he's gotta get he's
gonna be 2 under probably on those two
on the world at least at the minimum
he's got a birdie impeach never no
perfect Drive here that's true it would
be hard to broadcast a real golf event
and make it awesome all the time if you
couldn't talk about like regular [ __ ]
gonna be what those guys do yeah that'd
be kind of hard
no don't you think well yeah how was it
it was it was fine it's just we were
we're on online and it was 13 14 15 and
we did it for 12 hours a day so did you
talk about those three holes for trails
for two and here's player X at the same
pot is player why you see if he can read
this right as I write for six hours you
can get away with so not as much fun as
this no no way
I mean sometimes like if I were in your
shoes I would go oh my god it's such a
fine line for me to just break out with
a [ __ ]
suck my dick line line between just not
saying suck my dick and then just yes
they pulled that part like oh he pulled
that left or suck my day I I remember I
mean last year when we were calling when
we call this last year you were in
studio with us and we all knew that pot
broke left to right on 18 for Sergio to
win the to win the Masters and he
started it right the whole time Jim
Nantz and whoever's calling another
thing you go oh he left it out right and
it's like no it's like he [ __ ] up huge
yeah like cuz he I mean nobody knew
Justin I mean uh Justin Rose was gonna
[ __ ] up the 18th hole and you know the
playoff like he did but I mean he almost
like lost the Masters gave away the
Masters when he had it in four feet away
that's a tight outfit for he always
looks tight the mid pants with the white
shirt yeah with the no collar no collar
that's what Nikes doing those dollars
aren't you what do they blade collars
they're really good they're comfortable
I don't know I'm waiting for the mock
turtle necks to come back mock Turtles
are cool I love those things
those were around to cover those were
around for a minute yeah they covered up
one of my Chin's we're trying to get yes
per to call him but he said he might
have had too many libations before he
calls in but really hey Bo didn't stop
Jonas last year I know was he was me for
playing lakeside I remember last year
was it this awesome last year no thank
you
no that's right well we didn't have
Tracy calling last year we didn't
everyone needs a Tracy Collins weird a
way to open up man I know I kind of set
the bar a little high if you finish what
you started yeah we're going on yeah
Tracy wouldn't have called in though
stacks Boehner no not a chance
for the rel we yeah yeah that's okay we
get Tom but we never hit ready oh I
caught your set last night court you
were [ __ ] amazing I got this
to accord your jokes are so good that
one you do about your mom oh my god oh
my god your mom unbelievable see he's
got a tight look look sharp yeah he's
ready to go
I loved it the other the other day this
guy he's wearing his dad's clothes
I'm Patrick we know what he looks like
the world's tallest third-grader yeah
that's what he looks like
doesn't he yeah like you know that one
third grade my son's it they're great
means they play baseball there's a one
kids like holy [ __ ] he's in third
greater than everybody that agrees on
your son's baseball after three plays on
my case I get that that's that's could
you still look at his face like all that
guy's 11 yeah he looks like Josh Baskin
at the end of big when he like yeah you
can't pour him into one of those
form-fitting golf sure you could yeah
he's gonna look like Arabic Tech what's
that latex awesome what's the guy from
so good so stupid who's that guy from
Thailand is really good Kira that Jaffa
Barnhardt yeah you're gonna look like
you see like a he played him a master
would you just say Kira deck F a barn
wrap dude you gotta see this guy you
know I'm talking about half a barn rat
just remember that half of our tree the
big dig a hole bro let me say he's
gorgeous you know they're like I used to
really be concerned about my my stomach
and then I realized there's Tracy's all
over the world that don't really give a
[ __ ] what's how do you even begin to
spell his last name a pH a barn rat age
I barn rat all right so here's McIlroy
macro a big mouth green there it is
solid Wow
he's solid blows tubes like I'm styled
yeah but he wears tight clothes now he's
young dude that guy looks like a
toothpaste tube I love that guy guys
like yeah bro that guy is well you know
what's you know you talk about you've
never you've never played Agustin you
had what if you have it like like Colt
knows you look at
most who had the opportunity to play
Augusta as the amateur US Army trainer
and turned pro and has not been to
Augusta yet and probably won't get to
play Augusta I'd like to say cult was
you know but he has kind of been on the
decline instead of the you know instead
of the rise I mean he had a good year I
guess two years ago and got back on tour
and you know but kind of he's kind of
been up and down would you've ever
turned down that invitation no chance
yeah I I kind of look at that I mean
it's it's you turn for the week after
yeah yes exactly need the money with the
old money they like someone all right
but ten grand I can't why you don't I
don't want men why you would ever do
that you know I mean you don't you don't
pass up that opportunity about the
number again before just a case Tracie's
or any hey any guys for Chicago it was
his name Phil Steve that's my name if
you want to call in the phone number is
three to three Mike two eight two seven
four two four want to think like Darlene
thank you buddy Mike the head of all
things call me you came in and said all
this up force order pizza you're good I
love you Mike man
real real peace [ __ ] worst I walked
in and I was like who's that fake like
this get close
just sit down you say you know it's so
amazing cuz you come off you come off
eleven twelve and thirteen and then you
get to 14 which seems like the ho-hum
whole but just the one everybody [ __ ]
up on you know everyone yeah 14 they
kind of let because I think it's like
when you try you can attest to this to
like there's some golf courses where
there's that whole you can kind of let
you can kind of take a sigh and go but
you can't at agustin on the back nine
you can never take a breath there's no
bunkers on that hole but it's yeah God
probably the craziest group yeah just
enough now here's ROM on the 11th hole
it's got a long shot coming in which
actually may not be bad because it is
coming out of that first cut didn't spin
down the hill that's perfect
now phallic come on Ricky put this tight
buddy I wanna see a great angle here
here's another question
alright now we talked about who you'd
rather fight between Justin and Jordyn
who would you rather fight back to back
against three guys with well why are you
why are you I grew up stuff I mean
what's going to this I mean the question
you can either choose as a fighting
partner mm-hmm
John ROM or Dustin Johnson I take AJ I
take DJ game a couple snoots and you
send him right oh wait a minute hold on
no no it we have outside influence no
their message this is vice free no you
just go this is funny nobody you're
wrong
no right into this is straight like okay
we've got a John Rahm you want John
Rollins got European like fire fire
strength okay Patrick Reed oh whoa wait
Oh third fairway no way you're a half
but see there's that opening over there
on 11 there's a big drive here yeah
McIlroy Miss 5:05 par-4 so they moved
the tees up 10 yards no tracker on this
one no but it go it's in your mind you
know it looks beautiful perfect that's
that's amazing
all right hit it and just pick the TIA I
take DJ you snooze sending me on DJ I
can just blow I take Rob all day you
wanna [ __ ] throat you know like just
yeah yeah grill like that baby yeah yeah
did I got well I don't know I didn't
again I'm not gonna get into any outside
influence no this is just straight sober
fighting mmm like you're at Arctic right
you haven't been drinking from like the
guy you'd want to have you back kind of
thing yeah yeah I'll take ROM yeah I
take romick's we were just doing it that
way but I mean you you know you picked
yeah I get it
I take Pat Perez over John I true dude I
would take Perez take a parade okay out
of
and not not including Jason because I
would I take true but I feel like Pat
Perez is like someone he bets him like
10 grand and like they like well go to
my car and he'll he bent a [ __ ] iron
around your car [ __ ] oh [ __ ] iron
with that right so that follows you to
the car that would [ __ ] throw down
for you right look at that John Rahm
almost birdies 11 play golf but he sure
can fight oh yeah that press Kahlo's you
to the car yeah you got my trunk
all of it I want some collateral until I
see the money yeah following you to the
[ __ ] 80s see that you grew up with
him so you know ya know that's that's
you got it he's real deal he's real deal
I [ __ ] love that that's the guy you'd
want to have your back he comes our
shows member Peter laundered Oh Peter
laughter's big dude yeah Peter line no I
don't remember has an Australian guy and
Australians are always fiery my fighters
they define greatest guy Ian woosnum oh
yeah he's got his his wrist or bust tiny
right he's tiny but he's he's a fighter
dude so I was in Australia we were on
tour I was in Adelaide which is like the
[ __ ] wild bird it is do you like oh
my god you expect gunfights to break out
no cancer well you bet you know Bam
Margera okay so BAM happens to be also
in Australia and everyone's running
around Adelaide at night and [ __ ]
hammered and [ __ ] up I see BAM run
across the street and it was just very
ironic both of us were there and then
all of a sudden we he runs up ahead we
get up there about a minute later and
bam is laid out in the middle of the
street laid like knocked
[ __ ] out apparently he ran up he was
[ __ ] with these two Australian guys
who looked like footy players you know
Australian [ __ ] football and he was
[ __ ] he spit on one of them oh and
one punch [ __ ] snow angels
they love fighting they're always they
just they they're good at it and they're
[ __ ] strong but yeah they'll go out
and you'll fight a guy and they'll come
back and next thing you know like beers
they're fine they're drinking beers
right by each other beers like it's like
all right we got it we did it we knocked
it out we're good
Australian tours our buddy Ari Shaffir
is going on a tour of Australia this
week so see if you love to fight and get
[ __ ] up go see or I should be amazing
and then go knock them out yeah he's oh
that's great did he just do Europe he
did Europe yeah he does uh enter burrow
every year so I think that was a fringe
fest the fringe fest yeah that's cool
yeah Australia this week in position
this year that it looks like it's you
know would be a good fighter he might do
is he's a big big feet yeah like witty
ladies got he's got like a duck walking
he's he's got a weak ankles yeah I know
we do know that for sweeping sweeping
ankle yeah yeah
could he have well could he have gotten
a cart he don't you know how to do that
all right you got a walk if you can't
walk you can't play exactly now does he
take next week off to see like all of a
sudden oh yeah you see him next week
he's in a tear cast or something like
that walking boot well they said they
said they did the MRI and there was no
break it was a structure a no structural
damage yeah but the swelling had to be
nuts but it was Oh shots yeah you tear
ligaments in there and [ __ ] but they
said there was no tears all right it's
Fowler on 12
here we go come on Ricky stick it tight
aim it at the bunker and that's it camp
all-in-one anything more than nine nine
one you're calling it dude that looks a
little right to me what a golf shot by
Fowler on 12 he wish they had that yeah
that's a shove that's okay right you
don't want to aim there you know I he's
one of those guys that I love the fire
in him and when he gets going his win at
the Players Championship was the best
final round of golf I've seen since
Nicolas in the 86 masters the most
exciting like he birdied 17 four times
in a row
yeah that's unheard of and they were
right at it yeah I mean it was like
there was just no boy that's got to sit
down we need we need Reid to make some
mistakes Spieth is so we got Rita
14-under speech at 12-under
Fowler ROM and McIlroy all at 10-under
ROMs tee shot on the 12th at the tough
par three 154 yards everybody's saying
take it at the bunker and let it fade
Fowler went right at it
ROM does he follow no that's a per
that's that's job that's the shot right
there but you'd rather have his putt
than no no no you'd rather have Fowler
spot Fowler's got a little hot right
looks like you'd rather have his heart
rate and pull the balls in the air yeah
oh yeah I guess so yeah it's over the
pin out Fowler second shot at 11
arguably the toughest one that yeah yeah
since we're at this hole how incredible
was Leishman shot the other day when he
was what he hit that draw that was 15 I
was always 15 sorry yeah I was
unbelievable unbelievable did you see
that Lee shook so and then he was
playing with Tiger Woods and Tiger the
same thing a little bit not as great but
Leachman shot was unreal on fifteen-year
day going real quick back to Pat Perez
just got a text from my guitar player
Pat Perez has a party he wants us to
play in Ohio I don't know when so I got
to give him the bro deal yeah so is it
40,000 I'm just trying to hook them up
you know I get you know what no you know
what you do you to private playing in 45
yeah that's how many 40 and that's the
bro deal thank you no problem that's how
you make compromises see this is what
I'm talking about you doing 10 apiece 10
apiece plus flights right which hotel
what you do is you go you go you go 50
and then when you get there you go
you're such a good dude we're gonna
knock tin off see court you know how to
do it too yeah
yeah I like I like I like but I like
both trains of thought I like what you
guys are doing and I feel like together
I'm gonna make a bunch of money yeah I
thank you however you're gonna do it no
matter what happens somehow you're gonna
see Tracy in Germany I think it's um
yeah you know it
that's why Jesus offended planes yeah
thank you Jesus thank Jesus
yes yes he invented everything here
Jesus invented planes all right this guy
it kind of a disappointment
Dustin Johnson this year honestly I
think he he changed his game to be
better everywhere else except here
suited to the GUP not suited for this he
went to the cut yeah
and he just became a better driver the
golf ball yeah he wins the US Open
button means he's got it he's got a you
got a turn right to left of this golf
you play a draw right I play whatever a
heck I warm up with is that kind of like
in your mind though I caught it I mean
you're a cutter yeah if the guns to my
head it's going left to right because
that's what this pile of crap body I got
it does I get everyone does what they do
yeah
generally I love hitting draws well
they're more fun to watch and I do it
actually on the range I try to draw it
on the range to try to take away ROM
heard you guys and he backed off his
putt so here's Rob Spencer no no Johnny
this is a great thing for calling this
is like we don't give a [ __ ] right he
got a birdie putt on 12 he's my partner
I give a [ __ ] yeah this is your fight
partner this guy's got your back I don't
know this is a tough putt because this
one's downhill no after right this is
probably the flattest screen golf course
yeah but still got a little speed to it
here it is good looks pretty good looks
good looks good no turn divert
that's the thing is you got him you know
to make putts at Augusta you've got to
be aggressive and to be aggressive well
yeah yeah you have to be aggressive one
great oh my I just think there's shots
there there's putts there that you have
to like take advantage of
right because you don't have that many
of them yeah you know it's like now this
is gonna be a real test or par putt for
Reid because this is downhill it could
be the tournament I mean if he gets us
up and down it could be Sergio's 13 from
last year yeah you know I mean like
making par after especially this doesn't
pan out the way Rory would like I mean I
just kind of playing flat right now he's
not nothing's not really doing and he
needs to catch fire yeah I mean you know
Fowler can make this birdie on 12 and go
into the 13th hole you know we could see
something we could see something turn
around
but Fowler needs Fowler needs to birdie
12 he needs to birdie 12 he needs to
make at least yeah we need to see this
happen he's got an uphill putt he's got
a birdie this ya know yeah this has got
to because if you can birdie this and do
something on 13
you know something on 13 and 15 pot in
16 is a pretty good pretty good shot
what you needed yeah we got some water
there's a water right over there
yes Fowler makes birdie at 12 way to go
Ricky all right so we got Fowler coming
in now Fowler rolling in at 11 under
Reed 14 under Spieth 12 under ROM and
McIlroy still tied at 10 DJ could make
this on their own 15 get to 10-under
he's got a nice eagle putt like two-seam
getting double digits
no have you golf with Dustin mm-hmm yeah
I played with him in the first round the
fire I'm sorry on Saturday at the
Barclays in New York okay and make the
cut and I go up and I smash driver the
first hole kind of goes up and then down
and then up again back to the green so I
smashed driver there and I'm kind of
thinking like I have 40 I was 41 at the
time so I used to hit it long and now
I'm just you know father times
undefeated so I'm thinking like I'm in
let's see that he takes 3-wood and he
flies it by my driver I hand my hand
like Club too
my caddy Nago that's the last shot I'll
watch him here today yeah really that's
DJ so he blasted it by history would
like it was like like it was nothing so
he had some left on 16 he goes hey man
you see that see where that ball went
and I go nope he's a great dude but did
you guys chat at all yeah yeah it's
funny he's a he's a great guy he's you
can't teach six foot four you can this
is a huge pot right here any huge huge
pot and he misses it yes I'm sorry
wow that was cold [ __ ] blood rooting
against it's different than not rooting
the horse [ __ ] ruined it oh I'm sure
good for your buddy and that's okay yeah
you're ruined for Ricky forget that yeah
you just gotta [ __ ] up you just
celebrated a car crash no okay it was
out loud that was your outside voice
yeah damn it
alright alright come on Ricky here we're
gonna start rooting against Ricky just
okay yes he birdied 12 hookin enough he
looks like it if it gets down on the
ground
Oh perfect perfect beautiful enough to
get around the corner Wow
he's probably down there close but I
mean the thing with him is is he'll go
for it you know he has to yeah he's at
that time right now we asked it yeah man
well I mean so now he's two shots back
big shot Spieth is one shot back right
now this can't be more than five or six
iron from 205 downhill yeah oh let me
get enough of what to saying I think oh
no he's fine and not an easy one too but
if you anybody patting that who do you
want putt that that kid right there
jordan Spieth John ROM yeah yeah John
roms the answer to everything
so McIlroy and read both I think reads I
think
birthdays over I think he's done I think
that just took all the air out of rory
mcilroy [ __ ] Rory um now John Rahm he's
a cutter right what do you mean oh no of
the boat oh the ball okay I thought wow
that's not a cut no he just drew it and
he hits it so far oh my God look at that
oh my goodness I'm tweeting out the
video of that guy who had sex with the
hole and and used the flag to have sex
with himself just in case anyone's
interested the link is up now on my
Twitter dude I gotta get goin soon man I
have an appointment at where an asian
massage parlor youth they take
appointments now at the one I go to
just tell Bambi it's her name her name
is Ren de Ren de got it Rinda rub you
wrong wrong rear-ended it right get Ron
Ron runnin he's gonna take a piss or
something like like you know what none
him no more I've done enough so I can do
what do you want from me [ __ ] win
this whole [ __ ] thing he's like oh la
no I got a private jet
Pat Perez has one does he really I don't
know he better if he wants steel pants
about yeah all right so this so now what
do you do you come off you come off the
11th all you both bogeyed you're now now
it's tight now it's really tight now
you're kind of getting in the situation
where yeah I aimed for the bunker and I
hope I hit it between the two bunkers
and on the green oh you know both hands
are on the steering wheel right now
you think so I think so too I think
there's a little bit a little bit of
fear I think but I will say this though
got a par 5 one guy can bounce back
after a bogey it's this guy Reed I think
Reed's got the confidence and I say that
he's looking at who's got the yes gone
yeah you have a great shot right there
now Matt track I mean McIlroy he's
that's about the putt Jordan made right
you're not gonna yell damn it after you
hit that green no yeah no way to go
you're the worst Sportster ever no sir
sir he's actively yeah actually it seems
like you uh did you Jimmy the Greek is
that who I'm dealing with over here and
I have my draftkings t-shirt on hell
yeah Oh Oh get it McElroy on get well
Wow
yeah now he's gonna give read re nice
read damn it
thing is he agree to read no very
fortunately for Patrick Reed yes
good for him I think I think judging by
the depth of tan in your forearms you
golf the most I think those are rich
those are rich forearm yeah yeah pigment
really nice have you been playing are
you staying at how you staying only top
form your I'm trying yeah yeah so when's
your next tournament a week after next I
got next week off going to Oxford
Mississippi
oh that's a good tournament now the
budding metropolis of Oxford yeah yeah
that's it where is it the Arkansas Ole
Miss okay no let's see I'm playing web
events are you playing well I'm doing
right now I'm not gonna play web next
year so it's like tour card or bust okay
but you're still getting in some tour
events yeah planing a few here and there
yeah but okay miles do how is this your
bin on the web for you it's good I'm
25th on the list right now I finished
second in Columbia a couple weeks ago
and that's great and it's so it's gonna
it's gonna it's top twenty-five right
yeah so when we were so we were playing
golf the other day a few months ago and
you talked and I gave you advice to play
one more year you took my advice I took
your advice
take my advice to stay top 25 yes yeah
thanks yeah I would say I was gonna tell
you do it I'd say win the whole [ __ ]
thing all right that's a different
that's a little different well a little
room on either end that's enough you
know but but the one the one great thing
about web
and even if you're not top 25 you do get
the four events at the end of the year
now to go out and and have you know if
you've changed if you've had a mediocre
season and you're you know you're in
there you get four events that if you
and if you literally finish in the top
five and anyone four of those events you
get caught here so I mean I think that
that's a great a great team they're
doing it's a four week yeah school yeah
and I think it's very different than I
think the way Q school used to be set up
where you know is six days of just
brutal is it is it the is the four days
of the twenty six and above no so it's
the top 75 on the web and the one 126 to
200 on the PGA Tour and if you come in
what what position they played like you
don't live Spa 25 extra
Eagle pot right here I think he got a
little tender with this but maybe not as
tender as we thought he's gonna have a
short yeah he just tapped close you just
tapped that how how do the players feel
now with like that quick turnaround so
say you know things girls plan you
finish 10th and now you got to hit the
ground running probably the next week
right because it the turnaround it there
is no more offseason there's no more off
season if you want to gain points to try
to keep their you got to start winning
those ones or getting on those ones that
are in November and December right I
mean it depends how you are if you come
off playing well in the finals and let's
get after it yeah you know all right
this is a big shot right here was our
second shot on 13 going for the green
that's left
yeah sorry tell you where it wasn't
going yeah wasn't water no no and now
he's got a lot of green to work with you
know it's just real important to make
birdie here do these guys ever skull oh
yeah oh yeah yeah they they changed the
rule now where it used to be if you
double hit a chip it was also a two
stroke panel yeah now it's not no it's
not I love that right now it's you know
you know no it's not even a penalty at
all though you know it counts as
whatever wherever the ball ends up it's
just that stroke that might have enough
speed it might have enough speed Oh when
we tiger
here stop there that's another giant
third grader yeah yeah he's a great kiss
Australian he plays with he plays
partners with my buddy Jonas blixt in
the in the New Orleans tournament they
won last yeah they won last yeah we had
more fun named Cameron Smith he had a
five hour rain delay and I was caddying
for Freddy Hawkinson last year in New
Orleans they had a five hour rain delay
and I sent and told those guys [ __ ]
with him and Jonas for five hours I
can't believe they actually went out and
played golf after I just mangled their
brains with bull she's not a great it's
not hard yeah where'd you see that ship
yeah still was that Ricky yeah he left a
little short
oh did we see Ricky trip already that
that was just him I thought that was
wrong shot I think that was Ricky I
couldn't tell the pants are very similar
yeah I don't think something goes wrong
I was yeah
how do you confuse he does everything by
pants court I do I think my outfits
we've already talked about birdie huge
burden that might be the Masters that
might be the Masters right there see
dudes I gotta go I don't want to go but
I gotta go you got to do what you got to
do brother sometimes listen listen Rinda
is waiting it's great to see you brother
Brenda just exiting yeah from the only
burly were you guys were you guys going
out were you gonna be out or um next
week we go to Boise and Sacramento and
then we have Vegas on the 24th okay and
then we go out for a little East Coast
run April 26th through May 5th then we
go to Australia Australia yes in May all
right for five shows of debauchery he'd
been walking boxing yeah yeah I'm gonna
fight kangaroos down there sir
it's gonna be off all right buddy
no we're glad you're leaving tonight
yeah we could just say she you're here
is still though she calls she won't know
the difference
all right be good sticks in any for
Steel Panther
got to make this putt today what this is
uh this is huge
all right jordan Spieth for birdie on 15
he's got about a four footer this is I
mean this is make her die right here he
has to have this yes is he gonna have to
have a couple more birdies coming in
slick all right in there is all right
the one okay so Spieth it goes to 1313
standing ovation from the crowd in
Augusta three holes left he's got to get
at least another one right yeah he's got
it I mean I think I think 15 or 16 wins
it I don't think I don't think 13 is
gonna get there but you know we'll see
they both birdied 12 impressive health
read and and Jordan
all right here's Ricky's chip he's gotta
get close or put it in to stay with
these guys boy come on keep going keep
going down the hill keep going down the
hill all right he's got a good look at
birdie good by the way if you guys want
to call in the number is three to three
to eight two seven four two four three
two three two eight two seven four two
four happy to take your calls let us
know what you think about what's going
on today we are at all things comedy
studios court McGowan Steve Rannazzisi
Jason Gore is out giving Styx a putter I
hate that giving him a new Scotty
Cameron Circle T pissed me off John oh
really
yeah that's what that was for yeah John
Rowe misses the birdie drops done I mean
I should say he's done but he's 11-under
he's not gonna make a move here this is
a huge putt for Rickie Fowler a huge
putt Rickie Fowler I mean it's a six
footer that you got a make on Sunday if
you want to win them but this is that
putt that everyone no one has read right
all week
no one key no one reads this putt right
they had a putt similar to this on Fri
and the guys just kept miss reading the
putt miss reading the putt so it's good
to go left to right right not not as
much as you think though can't tell from
the front angle looks like it all slopes
down towards my daughter but it doesn't
break as much as they think it does and
I'm hoping he's got a good read on this
and we will see Rickie Fowler for birdie
on 13 he's got a bits about a 10-footer
he always says that back off where he
looks at it too we'll probably make sure
the lines right yeah make sure his lines
right on this putter I mean on his ball
he does he does a line on his balls all
right here it is kids here it is I say
makes it I say yes it's gonna make this
putt he's gonna make is the free throw
for him he's gonna make it here we go
[ __ ] boom
Fowler goes to 12-under par all right
he's still got four five he still get
one of those another birdie uh he can
get to 15 yeah absolutely
I mean I think I think I think 15 or 16
wins it like 60 and I think this is
gonna this is gonna eyes tied at 15 this
is gonna dictate a lot right here that's
money Oh perfect draw yeah that is huge
that is massive on the right side that
is a perfect tee shot from Patrick Reed
on 13 you know I mean yeah here's Spieth
on 16 I mean he almost needs a
hole-in-one here to do anything it's
walking at it like he likes it no wow
there's a club short that's a club short
dude yeah how do you go a club short
yeah I don't know what the I don't know
what these guys I've all I've heard all
week is about it's not you can look at
the trees to where the trees are
but in what's it's what's happening
above the trees I know that but yeah but
they're like wait I don't mean I don't
care
they're inside this little you know
there's trees all surrounding it there's
not that much wind he's not hitting it
above those pint
you know he's hittin it up in the air
but he's not above the treeline that's
all I've heard all week it's like you
know the what's going on above it is
dictates really where the where the ball
ends up it does look beautiful I have no
idea how Haley it was and that it's like
almost like a difference of two hundred
and fifty feet in elation yeah
undulation yeah you like that work I do
like that work but yeah I didn't realize
how like how many Hills have had and
stuff yeah it's crazy out there
yeah beautiful though I mean this is a I
mean I don't want to be a member there
though if anyone from a Gus is listening
I not interested in being a member and
either by no no not even a plane there
no I was just good enough to watch it
yes all it makes me happy yeah I would
never want to be a member know Augusta
National I've got to say this though the
fine people at AT&T and the corporate
sponsorship yeah great job what a great
group of people everyone over there just
is it you know from top to bottom yeah I
mean this is as far as I need to get and
we need to get up there and play that of
course no we don't get to that medium
court and I will be in Charlotte in a
couple weeks doing the comedy zone yeah
the second weekend in May so we
definitely want to play Quail Hollow
either that's not something we're
interested in I think it's okay to say
you want to play Quail Hollow so like it
goes no we're gonna do the thing where
we Nigam oh yeah yeah we definitely
don't want to play quell all right
nope not interested in Quail Hollow at
all all righty when Lori McElroy on 13
second shot from the rough I mean he's
got a hundred and ninety two yards he
took a good swing at that yeah he's
seven happened oh good shot but isn't
gonna come down the hill it might come
down here it comes he's not gonna come
far enough down he needs a couple feet
wait but done yet here's the good news
is now Reed hopefully Reed took a look
at that he takes an extra Club and puts
in the back bunker oh no I don't know
we're supposed to be no no no no no all
right all right we got buddy
Fowler birdied a net six footer and
birdie the Fowler made that one Romney
had a par I mean I read by the way reap
all meld it
down yeah you know nose raw yeah 13 hit
it and write down the left's the right
side but he's got like 180 180 something
end yeah there he is
grimace
what are the chances Reubens shirt yeah
what are the chances he chunks this 0 0
just chunk I mean like a whole big piece
of turf and it goes and it just goes 160
yards right into race Creek right that's
exactly what I think before every shot
honestly that's where my mental game is
right now is our years look at my mental
game is I'm here yeah I'm looking at the
disaster but uh I bet you did they ki
loves look about that oh yeah it's a
great shot right the hole boy is he in
the creek I don't know they get that
reverse camera one that shows like we're
boy oh man that's Freddie couples I said
that's not yeah that's Freddie couples
right there that's meant to be right now
yeah yeah he better walk real gentle
that little purple giant if he goes
velcro like right that stopped that
right there I wonder because it didn't
hit up high on the green of roll back
it's not plugged either no probably
looks like it maybe it looks like that
little wall mark in front worth it and
kind of came back but stayed up but I
liked it better when they shaved with
their you know where if you if you hit
it there just went all the way down yeah
that's kind of interesting now I mean
look with his short game he that's an up
and down for him he went from you know a
par possibly yeah to possibly he could
put that in and end this whole [ __ ]
thing Spieth for birdie on 16 he's got a
long putt I mean these are is these are
is like money right are you kidding me
said jordan Spieth birdies 16 that's 140
that was a good 30 footer did you see
that Justin Thomas quote that he said he
goes we love this tournament Jordan
really loves
[Laughter]
Wow
Aaron are you watching any of this Oh
buddy you can come watch some of this
with us if you want
just come and join horn over there he's
no he's already talking to Tracy from
Germany he's got her on skype so that
gets him to 14 yeah so Reid and Spieth
are now tied at 14 under
although Reid has got to par five still
of yep and Spieth has 17 and 18 left and
neither one are easy holes no no but
this is not you know so there's really
look what we mean what tournament was
two weeks ago he was in contention he
had a chip the chip it from the the
green and then he left it short it
rolled all the way back he went like
this remember Patrick reading rolled all
the way back it's like two or three
weeks ago and you know strange things
can happen he could he can muff this
chip right now but this putt by Spieth
is just incredible I mean to just drain
this I mean people are missing seven
footers and he's making a thirty play
yeah you just looked and said are you
kidding yeah yeah I mean don't forget it
63 is the course record here yeah he's
9-under yeah yeah and 60-63 still was
round they were shot a major to somebody
sheet 62 I want to think somebody shot
62 tell me I thought Justin Thomas shot
62 in the last four it was open right
saturday win it so it was like you know
Saturday at the open I believe was it
yeah all right huge shot for Patrick
Reed on 13 I mean this guy he's I mean
looks like he's sitting really good is
that in the hazard no oh great shot
great shot not guaranteed though not a
guaranteed birdie
some of I'll Jordan missed but I would
alright here we go
Fowler on 14 you got to put this close
kid come on you got to put this close
it's like a big 9-iron for him 165 yards
Oh golf shot there kid golf shot
makeable putt - alright Fowler's this is
turning out to be a good we yeah you
know what two years in a row three of us
have sat in this studio and we've seen
some amazing final research it was real
fun because I was like but it was a
two-man race it was rows and rows and
Garcia this year on to it this year I
mean we've got a few guys in this all
ROM come on give him a read give him a
read get outside of that no I mean roms
not I mean he's he's at 11 he's not
necessarily up McElroy's done knock
which is surprising yeah I mean he just
kind of I mean I think idol group on
Sunday to try to get the career grant
grand slam and you know nobody's ever
gotten the career Grand Slam at Augusta
we didn't even to be the last one to be
there last one no one's ever interesting
is there anyone else besides him that
has all three but no but no uh Phil oh
no math no masters yeah anyone I'm
trying to think does you guys at home
look it up this DJ have DJ have some
masters you never want to pga though or
no DJ just got the US Open oh that's it
yeah I need yeah he doesn't have the
Open Championship that's true
[Music]
smashed it yeah you know his his miss
his miss is a is a write miss you know
and it's just when he's not turning you
know it doesn't turn over for him and so
this course it you can miss a little
right and it doesn't really penalize you
that bad the course that's up really
good for him except for these last two
holes yeah last two holes you got it
yeah you know thread the needle Oh
especially 18 18 right there new to say
all right huge putt for birdie on 13
this is a big big disappointing you
think he pulled it or just stayed that
was the line Oh
doesn't break alright so reparse 13
that's huge for Reid and Spieth I mean
from Ballard speed that's huge for them
Wow
I mean they're I mean the birdie on 12
was amazing but without that birdie on
12 I mean I mean the confidence has got
to be shaken a little bit right that
well I mean when you got a guy throwing
nine deep at you from out of nowhere
yeah any kind of thought you know this
is my tournament all right come on Ricky
so Ricky for birdie here on 14 this is
massive that's probably the name he
didn't want to hear creeping up from
behind no no you know all right there
goes Fowler Fowler for birdie
yeah on forward watch out if he makes
this yeah if he makes this and you know
cuz he's gonna go to 15 one back let's
go come on Fowler sink this kid come on
- touchy it's a delegates not good roll
I roll over yeah you're right hit a
right where he wanted to it just didn't
turn as much heat man had just a little
too much speed on that but I mean how do
you hit it any softer than that he just
barely touched all right oh look at that
it's turning into Tiger at this place
yeah I mean it for him it's like that he
wants to grab that mantle I mean amazing
this guy Spieth has had birdies at 1 2 5
8 9 12 13 15 and 6 yeah 5-under at the
turn I mean 4-under since then he
birdied 12 and I'll tell you right now I
you give you as a Betty man it's 5050
dozen birdie one of these last two holes
oh I mean yeah I mean especially where
he's at
now look at that took the break Wow
great putt from ROM ROM now ties Fowler
at 12-under
back-to-back birdies back-to-back four
birdies firown' now ROMs not necessarily
out of it either because he's got the
part they both have they both have 15
and 16 which are both very birdie bull
and if he hits a good drive down there
he's gonna nothing but a short I'm you
know there Fowler is a lot hits the ball
a lot further than people give out right
a few I played golf with him and I mean
I watch him and look at that when I run
one two three four five Cameron Smith in
the back and I think he I think he was
even part of the front yeah I was even
on the front he's 6-under on the back
that's what I love about what they do
and back nine at Sunday I mean yeah it's
always the same but it's always there to
get ya this you know make a score but
you can also make big mistakes that will
negate that score they want to have some
fun on this back nine I mean Cameron
Smith birdie 10 12 13 14 15 17 wow
that's huge
there's so much still to go here and
then you look at this 14th hole that has
likes it I hear it is 17 those towers
are always there they never those towers
are like yeah they're landing on
permanent here we go George 165 yards
what's he getting eight iron that's it
cutting likes it up on that level stay
right there all right
that pin position on 17 today is brutal
that is brutal it's there every year
yeah but I mean that's one of those pin
positions well yeah I mean any other day
short-grain yesterday it's fine
you know today is like you've got to be
so precise with what's going on there
all right guys we're getting down to
that we're getting down to the
nitty-gritty here
this is getting really interesting how
do you feeling health-wise I'm good yeah
no I'm good mentally I'm still a little
messed up and too physically I'm good
really yeah I mean I want to think Kyle
from it's just golf who tweeted out our
life Facebook yeah you gotta love these
guys there's so many great there's so
many great golf websites now but Jonas
blixt better be yeah taking his girl to
the airport Jonas who was I was talking
to we did I did a series of podcast with
Joey D and Eric he'll cough and so yeah
exactly to life yeah so we did all these
we did these series of podcasts and the
funnest thing about him was we did we
had Brooks koepka it was US Open
champion we had Brooks koepka in there
and we're trying to get everyone like to
like say who's a dick on tour or like
who's the thing and he wouldn't and I
kind of prodded and he and he comes back
with Jonas blixt he's not Jones likes a
dick but he goes nobody's slower he goes
that guy backs off his putt so often it
just drives me crazy
I just want to scream at him you know I
was classic wrong maybe a little right
no no trying to hit that too hard yeah
you can get away with it and get in the
grass at least I don't think does it
make a difference it's gonna get
different like when you watch Tiger I do
like that whole thing that the dailies
in the woods he's like spending 20
minutes like clearing can you get that
guy this way they're only gonna let him
do that if it's like my first Masters
right and I'm up in there I can't spend
20 minutes clearing these certain
individuals I know there's hey [ __ ]
just keep going along there's definitely
a rite of passage yeah you know we're a
four-time champions gonna be able to you
know like it Phoenix when they move that
blow that falter for Tyler for Tiger I
mean yeah I'm like hey they're telling
me to hurry up yeah get out of Tigers
way no I don't know hangs in there it's
cutting rate just don't bounce too far
left
but that pins right more riders today
big shot for Patrick Reed here of 1400
and he sticks it tight Wow Toshi's not
[ __ ] around today he comes right back
he comes right back I mean is there's no
give up in him gotta give him that no I
feel like it's the first of 16
you know first person was 16 under 116
is gonna win that's what I think I think
16 that's what I'm saying if speed can
get it's got a burden the last 2 it's
like it's kind of running out of holes
that's a good swing cutting enough and
that's the amazing thing about this golf
tournament it's not like any other golf
tournament you can't go at pins you've
got to hit two certain spots on the
green with you know you've got to hit
two this yardage I mean if that was that
shot McIlroy hit is 15-year 10 yards
shorter it rolled off the field no it
actually feeds down to the right down oh
oh yeah I was I was on the back of it
practicing us the TPC Valencia with
Corey Pavin cool I was back there and I
said I get started ask them a few
questions and he goes you don't have to
be accurate at Augusta National you have
to be precise
yeah and it was like wow that's pretty
looks like a heavy yep yeah like you
don't have to be you know I don't have
to make it go straight you have to be
straight and know what your numbers have
to be so exact because 125 versus 127 is
a huge difference in where the ball ends
up you know you could end up off the
green in a bunker over the green with an
impossible shot to come back whereas any
other most of these other golf courses I
mean there's places obviously you don't
want to miss I mean I know as a caddie
from being out there it's like we have
in our book you know that don't miss
areas like where can you go and it's
like well we can't you know you don't
say to your player don't go right but
you know they'll tell you I mean
obviously you guys talk about it right
like hey this is the well look at it
together but you never say to your
player cuz you never put that in their
head you never say hey you can't miss
right you just go are you looking so
we're not gonna go right but we're gonna
you know you don't say that yeah you
know you're better off yeah you kind of
give them like a cone to hit in mm-hmm
you know it's like the pin is the left
part of the cone you want to miss it
somewhere in this right yeah yeah you're
like okay yeah ideally we want to be
right here you know five yards right
won't kill us
Oh God
you say because if 20 you know you know
because if 15 yards left is death you
don't go whatever you do don't hit it 15
yards left yeah I think like a good way
to look at Augusta is you have to make
aggressive swings too conservative
targets yep yeah exactly I think that's
I think you know any made any majors
like that really and I think especially
when you look at these guys that are in
the top that are here they're so dialed
in with their players about knowing
exactly you know exactly what they do
everything I don't think anybody's got a
caddy has it been all like oh gotta call
you back buddy gotta call you back
oh my god wow that was weird
it just happened me I probably did it
looked like it did I'm gonna call no you
don't think so we had to speed it looked
like it was gonna make it there we lost
something here I guess we got it we got
to kill it again all right we got to
kill it all again I'll find out if he
made it all right here we go hang on a
second we got to kill everything he
don't take everything off technical
difficulties here folks a difficulty is
everybody and then we go to broadcast
and then we got to go there we go oh
great shot by Fowler
either he missed it or this hasn't
updated it yet alright cuz he's still at
14 the the savior of the wife called
just texted and said Jordan misses on 17
ah thank you honey
yeah I'm sorry for our behavior too we
had no idea wives were listening she
gets it yeah that's all sticks man so me
and a guy Tracy from Germany what are we
gonna do damn it I mean great good way
to go way to go Patrick Reed Oh
[ __ ] alright so reads it 15 speech at 14
I hate reads caddies sunglasses just put
that out there
although obnoxious all about the
fashions there's white pants white pants
are great yeah
alright here we go
all right get in the clubhouse at
15-under and I watched myself ink 16 I
think you got to be at 16 don't ya I
don't think he wins but I think he puts
himself in a good position I mean you
never know what's gonna happen but I
mean Fowler is now on the green oh no
look his goes down
Sergio yeah that's different grass
that's different kind of yeah that's
that's a masters that's the master see
you next year
thanks for playing yeah now you can wipe
that stuff off your face oh that's his
top ten damn it what did you say that
was supposed to be like some sort of big
Spanish it was a branch or something you
said what's up with the homo whatever
you know yeah it's a painting that can
mean whatever it was loose translation
yeah that was uncomfortable Oh people
big babies got the swing up dammit
alright
Spieth one back man tee shot at 18 I
mean really the only people really in
position now I mean Fowler's got a
little shot at it still I mean the big
drive right here yeah this is in a tiny
little you know what single-file up
going up there mashed it oh yeah hold it
he's left into the bunker oh boy is he
left of the bunker did he catch the
trees he's oh my god
he's gonna have to easy have 3-wood he's
gonna have 3-wood to the green on 18
there's no fee they got an ally I worked
at Bobby's got an ally he's got an ally
so we're landed like all the way back
all right
just pull this deep into the woods on
the Left I mean hit a good shot now you
cut that's a layup yeah because that's
the one where you have to wrap it around
around the trees well one in the woods
but at least it was left there are trees
involved somewhere yeah see what I'm
saying this is where he just got a
three-lane this is like when you hit a
tee shot hello I mean I mean it's almost
the whip out territory right there yeah
I have muffed ones into the trees before
I mean that's like when you see someone
hits a tee shot that barely crosses the
cart path in front that's what that is
where's the yeah it's just the tee box
they have that these are the members
tees for the handicapped forward - yes
yes they're showing the that came out
there doing the Bannister awesome though
I'm into amateur okay is it a US Women's
Amateur is it just like the Augusta
National oh well yeah but it's a you but
it's a world and I think really did they
ever do other tournaments besides this
there no no let me know they have a
member guest
what do you want to do everybody oh okay
now we haven't had a lot of calls today
thank God
other than Tracy I know I think sticks
paid that person I think that was
perfect by the way if you do want to
call in three two three two eight two
seven four two four happy to take your
call numbers on the screen whatever
screen I don't know what screen I'll
Facebook that day yeah okay
now the numbers up there calling Wow
he is I mean at that point you know it's
like your chance try to make four yeah
yeah I mean that's it somehow
Manufacturing fail yourself of
incredibly tough par 3 I mean at the
same time though I mean he doesn't care
about the money no no no honey he wants
to win I mean it he's gonna try and hit
a shot he's gonna either try to make
birdie or it's gonna be both he's like
Steve he cares about the Wardrobe yeah I
know that's right huh he wants that
green jacket yep I mean ends our meeting
like crazy you know I mean he wears
terrible hats though those little like
no domed yarmulke with a brim on it yeah
second yarmulke with a little tiny head
he's got no hair too he's like almost
completely he's like all the great ones
just like they they sweat they stress
themselves bald LeBron James tired you
see when a solar panel yeah I'm not
judging by any means but come on Ricky
drop this putt for Emma no drop this
putt for Eagle
sit down down all right good yeah he
went for it you know it wasn't sure I
loved Ricky's got dad bought already
what he felt it's got dad bought already
you think no dude he does
one of the hottest girlfriend oh my god
what is she a gymnast or something she
was a pole vaulter Olympic pole-vaulter
yeah
paging doctor hello there's a cut cotton
added I started started the bunkering
but it's not enough to you hybrid there
right we all can't [ __ ] smash it Gor
well no I mean I didn't know if he was
trying to he was just laying up there
that was hybrid having up and down from
there
I guess he picked up I don't you know I
mean why I mean why wouldn't you not hit
3-wood in just trying to give himself a
number he probably if it got too close
to that pin right there ah behind the
bunker that would have been four seven
under on the back hit that red bush hit
the bush moves over there well John ROM
for par it looks good oh just all felt
right there I'd had my blow off his head
oh so odd he does get angry he does get
that temper always got a terrible oh
yeah that was for park is he doesn't oh
yeah when the wha yeah but he's oh this
is a must make for Fowler I mean he's
got to make this and he's got to do
something special on 16 he just does I
mean cuz Reed still got 15 you know I
mean he's I mean he's got a punch-out
but still he's gonna have a hundred and
ten yards for birdie you know to get in
there so you wonder what if he knows
what Jordans doing yeah that's what I'm
saying is he looking yes all right I
would want my caddy - just tell me at
the beginning of ever he might not know
either it's not like they have video
scoreboard
well there is I think there is a
scoreboard coming when they when they
walk between 15 and 60 I think there's a
scoreboard up there cuz this is it'll
have a guy walking with them and like in
the crowd like you know like just maybe
hi guy yeah he's not going for this well
I hope he does is he trying to go
through he is he's just gonna hit a
little punching through the hide that's
good just running down the hill there
you go
hopefully he gets down in the bottom of
her flat line well not hopefully for you
court but yeah yeah but I mean I mean he
put himself in a great position you know
maybe he hits it really like tight and
then spins it down into the water yeah I
mean Sergio Liske yeah like three times
so right now guys for our listeners and
viewers it's 15-under for reed 14-under
for speed 1304 fowler those are our guys
13 14 and 15 rom it's over it's done
whose mom is this Spieth Jordans oh wow
team Spieth right there that's the we
and we you ever notice that he every
time he does interview you know he says
I yeah it's always we're looking at this
oh yeah we did a great job yeah we do I
always what throws him in and his caddie
his caddie make some money than me
that's real money does he fly private
everywhere I'm sure he does yeah yeah no
I don't think he's jumping on many
Southwest or no maybe an American first
class somewhere all right you're good
look good Wow
sit sit great shape there you go that's
another one if you want if there's
anybody you want in that shot yeah I
mean there it is
you know the amazing thing is throughout
this day is all the guys showing up yeah
Cameron Smith at 6-under ROM at 3-under
Fowler at 400 feet at 9-under Reed's
Thursday Friday Saturday really did it
for him because he's 1-under for today
that's it
1-under yeah but I guess with the
confidence going out there knowing that
but you got a three-stroke lead I know
but and I don't have to go I don't have
to go [ __ ] mid 60
I just have to go you know 70 but or
better yeah yeah and I'm gonna put
myself in a position I think that's the
difference between them and Tiger Tiger
was going mid-60s he wanted to yeah you
know yeah yeah I mean I think there's a
big good setter
sit yeah that's I mean that's the Tiger
one that's a shoe that's really
disappointing Patrick Reed just put it
over the green on I'm sorry I tried to
do it well oh you want it in the water
so he's your best shot here okay come on
Ricky put this thing hole in one hole in
one oh boy he likes it we would hear it
here
oh [ __ ] bunker yeesh sorry it's probably
very makable punker shot he's good that
really you know he's got the huge back
so he can Tiger it up there and got a
good lie yeah boy you can see where it
hit and it wasn't that far off from
being yeah all right here we go John
Rahman 16 let's see how fired up he is
yeah there it is best dialectic coach in
the world oh how funny would this be if
this goes in the hole after he slammed
his club I hope it goes in the water I
promise you if I did that there'd be a
certified letter my front door yeah oh
yeah you get you get a lot of do they
send you stuff whenever there's like say
there's a mishap out there or there's a
I've been fine
I've been fined once would you get fine
for ready for this is a great story yeah
so I don't know back in 1843 when I was
like young on tour I hurt my wrist okay
I came home got a cortisone shot went
back to played too early wood drew from
the tournament this was in Richmond
Virginia at the Dominion Club and had an
ice pack they gave me like his ice pack
they could yeah the whole cooler a beer
with ice right so I'm holding this thing
and the the door handle
for the locker room had a leg up yeah oh
yeah yeah I got like a door like a
handle on it like when you push down
I walk into player dine and go into the
lock and trying to get all my stuff and
I got this huge ice pack and charts
Vanderwall it's ex-wife now was sitting
there they said hey do you think you can
give me a hand and she went I I liked
Riggs take the door down blew the door
off the handles I got on me a hey I
still get emails from the pga tour board
for the you know caddies and stuff and
stuff and one of the great things is
they were talking about etiquette and
one of the last things is please stop
spitting on the greens we pulled it
again how does it I'm sorry but how do
you not know that putt goes that way I
don't look like a pole to me but I don't
know when you were on the when you were
trying to win the Masters did you yeah
what you get a little nervous hold did
you get the most no but I mean a heck of
a round I mean yeah dude 64 on Sunday
yeah it's the bed on g4 on Sunday oh boy
nestled it up there stop stop stop stop
stop stop stop stop stop stop I mean it
very nice putt nice putt there it is
jordan Spieth shoots a 64 on Sunday
pretty amazing yeah pretty amazing you
know I mean one bad swing yeah one bad
swing on the tee I mean you know you
gotta take a look back at him I mean he
basically shoots 5-under on the front
goes out in 31 all right
comes to the back nine birdies 12 13 15
and 16 and it's just that's a special
round and then you know it's not over
yet I think it is I think
I mean I don't think 13s gonna I don't
think 13 is gonna do it yeah I think we
might watch
I think Hydra Creed's victory March
over/under five green jackets jordan
Spieth now who's walking to his right
this is a longtime girlfriend
I don't know what her name is but he's
been around for highschool five green
jackets it's over under hold on oh boy
he's gonna really get it to the right
spot
here it comes come on get a little speed
get a little 3d turn left there it goes
turn left alright great shot there Ricky
found great bunker shot I mean he did
everything he could to miss a shot you
know he did everything he couldn't make
that so Fowler's gonna go to 17 T we
know at least two shots back this is a
slick little putt here yeah there's a
flick but but you know this is the one
thing that we've watched redo all week
long Thursday Friday Saturday and only
one today that one on was at 11 9 but he
has to birdie this I mean he has to par
this hole because I mean he was 4-under
on 13 and 15 on Saturday this is one of
those ones that can get away to the
right time he's just gonna stay down on
this one listen Gordon I've been making
these yeah there it is
alright so he pars it so now he still
goes when he's going to 16 with a 2-shot
lead and 16 sets up perfectly for him 1
yeah oh it's a tie drawn yes this is
perfect for him yeah you got Rob for
birdie with a pent 8-iron
yeah it's well no never never even got
that in the right nail that every time
I think you say it different every time
no it's always French even though he's
Spanish yeah there's a choice for me I'd
be basco wouldn't it
it's like Pepe LePew drunk yes look at
that poor guy alright Patrick Reed
stepping up to 16 now with a two-shot
lead I mean I mean he's playing with the
confidence I mean even though he's had
some he's had some someone asked to me I
never had a bit he's never had a bad
mistake yet he's made he misses that one
putt that was like a six footer that's
one on 13 for birdie been in the pine
needles a couple times out of it someone
asked him yesterday because he went to
the University of Augusta did you know
does he feel like he has a home field
advantage he's like no we got to play on
this course one time a year and he was
like we you know we played from like
nowhere near the tips or anything like
that
oh yeah so you know you don't think
they'd let him play from the back no no
I don't think it's during this I'd only
it has this much fire either yeah no I
never never would have this all right we
got a call coming in all right do we got
calling in all right well good job guys
dammit all right wasting my energy put
headphones are like messing up my hair
dunes my hat got tweaked a little bit
like Puma by the way all right Ricky
come on good swing
that's the one thing these announcers
are always going could it be his time
and it's like Auto I know but they're
just so but I would be interested to see
because I don't think either one of them
were to win but who wins a major first
out of the two of them well according to
this right now it would be Rickie Fowler
we'll see whatever on ROM can keep his
head on straight enough to win win
that's the thing he's just so much it's
maddening actually I mean when he went
up against DJ in the the match play well
last year it's like you know you just
saw this anger come out it was like wow
dude yeah things aren't that bad John
like just good driver I mean I think you
know typically I mean like what's how
many masters is Phil 1/2 3 3 yeah he's
won three masters he's won the British
once or twice once and he almost wanted
you know years ago when he's won the PGA
only hasn't won his US Open but he was
always that guy that was very you know
just kind of a casual about you know
didn't get real angry he let it come to
him yeah and he had a lot but he a lot
of determination I mean he wasn't you
know he was very focused and very in
there I mean that was the thing that
Sergio talked about last year he said he
just he'd never gotten in his own way
which is kind of what he did for many
many years got a call coming in again
all right let's wait to see if they
actually pick up who's on the phone
piece of [ __ ] if those guys who is this
Tanya hi Tanya how are you I'm okay how
are you I'm good where are you calling
from love Germany nice the Germany of
the south go ahead go ahead
thank you I just found this number I was
just looking through my tweet and saw
stick said I know I missed it we knew it
with sticks yeah dude let me tell you
something about sticks okay where you
got this number from ma'am but sticks
ain't here anymore okay you went to get
an STD treatment yeah you were to get
yes get in line because there's a chick
from German it's all ready to blow them
so unless you got that on the table
right away ma'am we got it we got to cut
ties with you okay I'm stix's agent are
you watching golf today what are you
doing
are you watching golf are you watching
golf are you are you watching the
Masters going back to work at my
computer and just was looking through
some tweets before I got back to work so
oh are you golf fan do you are you
interested that's what we're doing here
watching the Masters and we're kind of
talking over it so it's a live
commentating along that's what sticks
was here but are you a golf fan do you
enjoy it at all for anyone I mostly
Colin because I thought I thought could
possibly be a a cancer tribute wine or
yeah now let me ask you something Tania
when you're when you call in from Texas
and you're calling for sell Panther what
are you wearing well that's all what
kind of mom you are yeah again the first
offer is my job so if mom smoked some
weed before she calls today got a good
giggle going very positive person I try
to stay in this world I try to stay
positive
find humor where I can and you can break
place just cracks me up in being a young
adult from that era of music it's just
pretty funny I just I just like that
band and I'm teaching my daughter how
men think by letting her listen oh my
gosh well we're doing a good you're
doing a service ma'am I'll tell you this
right now
I hope you have a great Sunday enjoy the
rest of your day and enjoy the masters
if you get to watch it again yeah oh
yeah I will hey no problem well tell
sticks you said what's up no problem Wow
I gotta say right now we need to give it
band yeah we should dump these mics and
guitars in Arizona I need a I'm going
with this Dix's agent thing yeah you
guys I'm gonna negotiate all his deals
yeah with his penis yeah
all right so Fowler just hit on the 17
rolled off just a little bit gonna have
a tough chick Oh blow him that was like
Korean oh he just dies that's an
impossible shot yeah I mean he's just
kind of lost it now he is oh he broke it
he smashed he just ripped that 5-iron
over his knee and then realized he
couldn't vote Jackson it I guess you
can't throw clubs if you throw if you
just mat like it threw a club into a
tree at Augusta you just be like this is
the last thing I ever do here they don't
like to invite you I know I mean if
you're a top if you're top 50 in the
world and you're in in can they still
say no absolutely really yeah Wow how
would you like to be the guy that's like
22 in the world but can't go to Augusta
cuz you got it I mean you have to do
something but that's right here and I
mean if you'd like because it just -
fatica Lee he threw it in and it came
down and land
on some lady's head and he gave her a
concussion she's in the hospital for
three days you got it this is Reid if he
makes this he's Masters champion that's
going in oh if he misses it Rickie
Fowler's master champion yeah all right
so Reid misses the birdie on 16 is gonna
tap in for par would it be great if he
tiptoe then just ring it around that's
oh no that's not a gimme would that be
great so he goes pick it up any and he
just scoop just mistakenly scooped it up
I think if I might be wrong here I
probably am but like say Rory just
walked over and knocked it back to I
don't think it's a penalty I think he
just has to replace it yeah oh really
yeah
is there a penalty on Rory no I don't
think so
Wow somebody should do that like
seriously like just walk already hit in
the water like it's the ball in the
water like not just do it a little bit
like really like smash it all right
McIlroy to over for today yeah to over
surprising I mean you know you got
Spieth 8-under Fowler 4-under ROM still
3-under Cameron Smith 6-under
Bubba Watson shot 300 today by the way
and putted he went into the bunker and
for the guys that are you know four they
were trying to make that top 10 to get
in Dustin Johnson back in and he's gonna
finish in the top 10 Tony Fein out good
for him 12 you know 12 in times Oh 12 in
tie so Hoffmann Rose mm who's taisen any
amateurs finished top 10 or 12 no God no
I mean the closest amateur was Jim he
was dug him he finished 50th and yeah
cuz he got a jacket or he just gets to
sit in Butler cabin he gets a sit and
bother cam and I give him a little
little jewelry I think okay oh yeah he
gets a nice bike it's a little get some
crystal and you know you upgrade that
like a gold-plated xbox or something
that would be awesome so instead of like
you know you win the Amateur you know
the amateur to your wrist 'el Tracy
comes over yeah Tracy comes over and
plays Xbox and are under in or under
where it gives you a blow job there
it is y'all huh oh boy oh boy
spending his knee ah that's not bad
no he's fine he's not gonna have an easy
shot but I mean now you've got
I mean Fowler's got to do something on
18 now I mean
can I ask a dumb question that the two
of you will know the answer to but
people might at home might not why do
you pull the flag out when you're going
to make it my only thought is this when
you want like if you were had a like a
little backstop like something to stop
it slow it down
well what Trevino's saying pin never
helps a good shot yeah yeah well because
if you're if you're any speed at all and
it hits the pin it's good of ricochet
off if we're gonna ricochet out if
you're if it's going in it's got a
better chance to drop into the hole back
back of the hole and dropping in then it
does but you know the worse the player
the better the chance that this ball is
gonna have some speed coming on but now
in some cases where you've got something
that's so severely downhill and you're
off the green it sometimes helps because
it's never gonna stop back the hole
anyway you're trying to hit the stick
just to get it to stop okay not your
only option yeah it might be your only
option but good spot around good par on
17 that's what he does like he gathers
himself so quick yeah just wears his
emotions on his sleeve and I guess he
has to get that out maybe listen I
understand I understand the you know the
thought of getting angry quickly and
then letting it go he's dude
what are you saying that I mean yeah I'm
saying I've had an outburst before one
or two yeah I've been around yeah I mean
we've walked off courses that we did not
pay to play because this guy's had
outbursts before that's literally
courses that we were like here don't
have enough to pay [ __ ] you I would
never play here again my [ __ ] yourself
that's how we're getting to the car
after nine I cheered
I did play I did play at Brookside one
time in a I have to pay in a pub Lynx
qualifier and it was all college kids
and all these you know these you know
these kids are getting their dads are
they're their parents everybody's
watching and it was three hours and 45
minutes for nine oh no that's out and I
walked by the scores tent after nine
holes I walked home and put my score
down scorecard down and I put a wd on it
and I go this is the worst [ __ ] run
tournament I've ever nighted said
[ __ ] tournament and my life you guys
should be a shame
of yourselves three hours and 45 minutes
there's no excuse for this you should
all go home
and I just said that and I walked out
and what tournament was it at Publix
qualifier oh my gosh
and it was three hours and 45 minutes
and I know that's not cool it's not cool
no and I was like go [ __ ] you it's
problem with golf now it takes too long
yeah you don't have a time to do that no
no no I mean I don't have to do anything
I still don't have time to do it right
it's just crazy
Wow Bob Watson yeah those shoes oh
you're wearing a red nose it's gonna cry
all right you don't know masters
champions ever shot all four rounds in
the 60s seriously yeah Reed Reed had
never broken 70 until this week right I
don't know oh good shot there by Fowler
he needs to make birdie here you can
make birdie here you know there might be
something there might be something to
come of it he's gonna have to make
birdie here though there's no way Regis
dropping two shots
I like the ROM still got some fight in
him he's still stepping up he doesn't
doesn't have that like slumped over Luke
no nor will he know but I mean he's
pretty much out of it I mean he's four
shots back I don't think there's any way
Reed drops two shots coming in I don't
think so either I mean he's got a tough
shot for Wow whoo that was pounded oh he
just killed that could have 9-iron in he
flew that to Ricky's ball
nah-uh
remember back in 97 when Todd you just
took it over that bunker oh that's not
much they've lengthen that thing yeah
all right now roms got a Romina Reed's
got a really tough shot here on 17
because that pin is way right
I think he's fat at a green up on the
left no I think he tries to leave it
short and short right and we're Ricky
was oh we got some problem couldn't tell
if he a tree trouble he had to cut it
looks like he tried to give it that well
his big cut swing he's been doing that
little kind of helicopter move at the
end of his swing just try to hold the
face off yeah you never know I might
have just out of that rough it didn't
couldn't put enough side spin on it or
something
there's he looks like a eats a lot of
chicken wings you expect he's a wing
eater doesn't know that a chicken wing
eater I'm not commenting again great to
have you in here though thanks ray
this is fun I this is so fun this is our
tradition absolutely next year when
you're there
yeah planted you can do it live on
location you can call it yeah we're
gonna do it live on location we'll
follow you around any even if you're in
it on Sunday I'll be your on course
reporter yeah yeah with Janet Jackson
yeah little fetus so Reed has got some
huge troubles here on seven oh really
well front left of the green roof just
short yeah just short front left so he's
gonna have to hit an amazing chip just
to get up and down for par nice so so
you must be happy why why would you say
his rig has Ricky Dillon describe to
tell the middle of the fairway only on
this is one of those times where it's
like you know you work so long and so
hard to get to this position and you
know doing it now you think do you think
he's enjoying anything no notice it yet
no can't enjoy he just trying to run out
of holes right I think the only day you
really enjoy gusta is Wednesday I think
the only day really enjoy it I mean deep
down he's having a good you know this is
where he wants to be but you just can't
run out of holes fast enough at this
point I don't think dancing for birdie
on 18 to go to 9-under PAR post a great
score way to go ahead have it he has a
sharp look for a green jacket
he was were ready prepared like look at
the green accent in this shirt well I I
remember meeting him at the Honda years
ago and I was with yes / and yes / goes
he's a weird dude and I was like what
for yes / to say that because let's say
he's a weird dude I was like holy crap
that guy must be a weird dude and he
didn't mean it like in a negative like
he wasn't like he's just like I don't
think he said weird eight I think he's
an odd guy he's one of the funniest
dudes out there it like we're really
funny yeah yeah random oh that's great
like it's just that dry kind of yeah did
you see last year when he drove up on
Magnolia Lane he was bumpin vanilla ice
oh that's classic windows down look at
Joe got the shirt open there got the
guys why don't you know did they give
you that thing you get to keep that
little jumpsuit a little whisper Roger
back does he whisper whisper rock he's
pumping it out there 8-iron looks like
come on kid Ricky Fowler Wow
some big cojones right there that's
awesome
third shot
let's go that's carrying some speed
folks oh do you think Jesus Nance he did
it just last broadcast that's false
okay he's a member right Jim yeah he's
one of them and les Moonves I think the
only entertainment people that are
members and the guy that runs CIA's
music Rotter light hello friends
man I caught a lot of holes in him if
the if the sticks not in with that going
no I don't know that was a hell of a
shot though the only thing is you don't
really get a good look as to what I
still or read as to what it's gonna do
because it ricocheted right yeah it's
just so slow going up that hill I mean
he's got to make this
you just got to make this
let me not Reed's gonna I mean I was
just hoping it wasn't I mean I was kind
of thinking maybe if we'd made yeah
that's gonna be tough cuz Reed's gonna
more than please no picnic you know you
gotta hit four good shots at least three
yeah I mean look at the phallus aller
kind of had a rough Fowler didn't get
off to a good start that's his problem
he he made mistakes on 2 & 5
whereas big mistakes he should have
birdie 2 but he you know he got up and
down from where he did but you've got he
you know the bogey on five killed him
but you know he ate 9 birdied and that
was great and you know he's gone he's
5-under senses since his it's a good
five and a half six feet here yeah he's
gonna make this yeah he just poured it
right I was a hell of a par four Patrick
Reed on 17 now he knows he's got at
least a one-shot lead going into 18
don't exhale yeah don't Patrick man here
we go work it's coming down again but
Fowler's gonna have to birdie yeah make
this even interesting I think Fowler
doesn't birdie there's no way he's
making triple bogey on on [ __ ] 18 this
is a must make this is a must make for
Fowler tonight looks like
left center yep that's exactly what
that's what I'm saying one DeMarco made
a couple times Vinnie how can that play
off of them oh yeah they play it twice
right all right here it is Rickie Fowler
here it is this is big he's putting come
on kid
bricky come on did you make this yep
yes 14 alright alright Ricky Fowler
Clubhouse of 14 alright so it's coming
down it's coming down to 18 again here
it is Ricky Fowler
I mean he really played solid from the
eighth hole wand I mean just solid oh
boy that's a Honaker that's in the
bunker looks like god damnit huge tee
shot oh man you got to wait there I'm up
one short come up one short that is just
yeah that's a great building block for
him
yeah the way he drives a golf ball he
could be yeah he could be I mean he
comes out Shinnecock he shoots 67 shoots
back-to-back 67 that's a great weekend
you know absolutely you know you gotta
say you know you can't you know you just
can't you can't knock that man you can't
knock that or back excuse me shot 65
yesterday she's 65 yesterday in 67 today
you know unbelievable
now for as much as a building block that
was for Ricky now is this kind of a
opposite for John Rahm I don't you know
I think like you said I think he gathers
himself quickly and I just think it's
like you know he's still shot 69 yeah I
said oh he thinks he's good enough to
win it
no matter when he teases yeah but he
just has to control it's gotta find a
little peace yeah he still shoots 300 on
the final round
you know shoots a 69 you know finished
his fourth you know the last huh he just
bogeyed the last hole
who was that for birdie no that was yeah
I was party he made par par so you made
par on the last hole so relax look at
his girl there though with the hat on
and the fedora I mean looks like there's
some fans were in for him yeah holding
hands come on we'll see I mean I mean
he's he's he's like that at me yes he
said some man that's um well you get to
be popular he's branding himself very
well yeah he's branded himself because
to be honest I mean if we're being he
doesn't have the win resume of what guy
that has his popularity
you know celerity and he's part of that
is the way he is with people he's great
I'll tell you it I'll tell you a story
is we I was having I had dinner with him
in Jupiter Florida one time with he'll
cough and where is it this Mexican
restaurant just this out-of-the-way
Mexican restaurant just three have said
dinner we walked down we're standing out
front getting ready to walk to our cars
and we're all talking to each other just
having a conversation a little kid comes
out in a soccer uniform with his dad
probably six seven years old the kid
comes out and I see him and we all see
him tug his dad's sleeve and he goes
daddy that's Ricky Fowler Ricky turns
around stops talk to us turns around
goes over to the kid and he goes hey
keep my name yeah
he walks over and he punches the kid he
goes do you ever [ __ ] say my name my
name no but he walks over but he walks
over says hi to the kid and like signed
something for him and it says how was
your song how was your your match yeah I
think he's got grand that is the kind of
people root for me look at the tan lines
owner she could do spray tan a little
bit I'm always with the high-end
expertise analysis we judge here because
we're perfect truly are color commentary
man yeah what'd you think of her outfit
Steve it's leather so I have two
dejected I am a faux leather man myself
Naga no delivery so I'll go for the shot
of Patrick Reid's life right here here
it is yeah are there nerves in this do
you
I mean I know there's nervous yeah now
he's fine no of course he's yeah Diane
how do you say anything like within 2530
feet
how does make a Big Sur how do you not
like literally what I don't want to do
is have to go up and down yeah you know
I'm saying like I don't want to put it
in a bunker I don't want to have to chip
it I want to be able to have two pots to
[ __ ] win it yeah that's all I'm that
that would be well I mean I think he's
gonna I mean obviously the way this
guy's played today he sticks it tight
you know sure you can say that no I can
still get fined Wow but if you were to
say something like more nervous and a
fat dog on a Korean refugee but here it
is here it is let's see if he can
control his adrenaline right now perfect
little boy oh boy is it slick right
hee-hee babies that putt up to two feet
yeah I mean and then he's got a
two-footer yeah I mean it doesn't have
to worry about hitting it does he know
he babysat up there that was an
aggressive wine right there yeah that
was an aggressive line all right Roy
just one good shot ty it's Marty in
knock it in go to even for the day swing
he just never I didn't see that coming I
didn't either I mean I mean we first saw
it and I mean you know he started off he
birdie too and he bogeyed three birdie 4
and boat and then he's just been out of
that I've been out of it ever since
you know his bogey on a was like
literally I think the one that was the
dagger because you know then he went par
bogey you know he birdied 13 but bogeyed
14 and then you know in part fit was if
your wheels were awful not that you want
anything missing but if you were missing
your irons you're putting or your driver
going into Augusta which one would you
least miss you can't have any
I mean maybe because I feel like his
irons have to be off because he drives
the ball Rory
I mean puts himself in great positions
but he's not gonna thing I mean I would
say driver just because there's not you
know there's no there's no real rough
drop it I mean I mean if you were could
still get out you have to be on your own
game around Augusta you can kind of I'm
guessing get away with a few errant tee
shots hmm but you cannot but your putter
has to be high we are yet to win I mean
your irons have to be impeccable to put
yourself in the right position do they
have other sighs yeah you know you got a
big vibrator on that phone thank you
phone sax two parts well I hope you guys
enjoyed the all things comedy masters
companion yes yours is fun again it's a
good time
Ben you saying man he shrugged over the
man party you guys bent you guys man
yeah we met out in the hallway earlier
all right maybe there's a penalty shot
somewhere that we don't know about that
we could maybe get you might double hit
this putt and can we call in it can we
call in a penalty shot just that just to
make it like your fashion piece yeah get
the jacket till tomorrow till they
review it I have to watch it
who put it in really good no really good
he'll finish that well does he finish it
I think so could be writing reads
through line though I think he finishes
does he yeah he's gonna finish it means
nothing
McElroy is in he's you know still
finished his top five but to over par is
not not the way you want to you want to
leave a gust on Sunday you know his wife
you know Reed's wife caddy for him for
years
Justine yeah yeah really yeah she's good
now her brother's oh she uh like a
collegiate female golfer I don't I don't
know but she was but she was his caddy
for a long time and I mean she's a
little bitty girl - I mean that bag was
like it looked at hysterical like her
carrying it it looked like it almost
drugged the ground that she knew it'll
no roller skate on the back of yeah but
then when she got pregnant her brother
started stepping in and he's been on the
bag ever since yeah buddy you gave it a
hell of a final round by Ricky Fowler by
the way 67 finished 14-under I mean did
everything he had to do yeah it still
does not get a good on television that's
a green jacket on this shirt this thing
yeah if you're watching in 4k yeah - now
I might want to turn it to black and
white yeah
turn down the hue he's gonna baby this
this isn't going anywhere blast at seven
feet by oh yeah I didn't even touch it
oh boy
all right remember Dustin Johnson the US
Open there's a four putt two three putt
that moves a little bit right now the
way no that's just Center no he hasn't
missed one of those yeah he hasn't
missed one of those he's not gonna miss
this one I wish he would I mean it's so
hard to move your body when you're this
nervous and but I mean that's what they
practical aid in enough tournaments it's
not as you know yeah you stand up over
this and just say you know what I've
made a million of these yeah further for
this particular reason right here she's
more nervous than he is oh I'm thinking
about the dinner menu next year bingo
[ __ ]
yeah well Patrick reads our winner this
year thousand eighteen masters Steve
Rannazzisi ank you buddy
Jason Gore thank you thank you guys from
all things comedy Erin thank you for
being here with us again today Thank You
Tracy
in Germany eggs yeah onion Texas and
thanks miss Lake for the pimento cheese
sandwich this is Gor for that yeah
[ __ ] fantastic congratulations Patrick
Reed aka Patrick Stewart commander of
the Millennium Falcon yes alright guys
thanks for watching we'll catch again
maybe maybe we'll do the US Open from
Bell be there so I'll call from let it
go Shinnecock yeah I'm going yeah heckle
sure it's gonna be Baba Booey all
weekend long don't be that guy please
don't be that guy with the hi alright
guys have a good one we'll catch you
next time thank you you should